le père de la terreur j'ai écouté le
président entrant pratiquer le déni en
oubliant carrément l'allier qui a eu le
triste privilège d'avoir le plus grand
nombre de morts dans la deuxième guerre
mondiale
mais si j'ai bien compris ils sont morts
pour rien puisque au nom d'une idéologie
on nie leur existence en oubliant une
partie de la game
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
pour deux heures d'émission décrypteront
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités toujours tenus à bonne distance
et nos reporters voici les titres de
l'actualité
les critiques sont vives dans les rangs
de l'opposition au lendemain du discours
d' emmanuel macron dénis surréaliste
auto satisfait xi réouverture des écoles
ridicule selon le rennais manque de
remise en question la locution qui
annonçaient le passage en verre de
l'ile-de-france et la réouverture des
restaurants et des cafés des chemins
teint est loin de faire l'unanimité si
la course au vaccin contre le coc u19
fait rage la question de la fiabilité
des études également plusieurs
laboratoires sont aujourd'hui en lice
pour la découverte de la fameuse
molécule qui préservera l'humanité du
virus
la société américaine moderna
therapeutics y figure en bonne place
mais suscite aussi les critiques au vu
de ses nombreux soutiens notamment
financiers
[Musique]
le vieux continent poursuit son
déconfinement les français peuvent
désormais circuler au sein de l'espace
schengen
une semaine décisive et diplomatique
attend aussi l'europe entre la relance
des négociations post break site avec le
royaume uni mais aussi la réunion des
chefs de la diplomatie européenne avec
le secrétaire d'état mais qu on paie au
point d'orgue ce vendredi avec une
réunion du conseil européen
aux etats unis le calme est revenu
atlanta deux jours après la mort d'un
afro-américain battu par un agent de
police lors de son arrestation les
mobilisations contre le racisme se
poursuit à travers le monde le conseil
des droits de l'homme de l'onu a donné
son feu vert un débat urgent sur le
racisme et la violence policière
demandée par les pays africains
[Musique]
les critiques sont vives de la part de
l'opposition après l'allocution
d'emmanuel macron hier la quatrième
intervention du chef de l'état depuis le
début de la crise du coronavirus jean
christophe lagarde président lui dit
damien abad président des députés l air
et sébastien chenu député est reine du
nord dénoncent tous les trois une forme
d'auto satisfaction du président à
gauche les députés les filles maintenant
aubry estime que la question du racisme
et des violences policières a été
balayée d'un revers de main pour jean
luc mélenchon le président du groupe
la france a soumis des buts et des
bouches du rhône il s'agit d'un discours
tout simplement inutile j'ai été surpris
si c'est moi ils ne disent rien et qu'
on continue à avoir l'impression d'un
homme qui cartonne dans le brouillard
est fait comme ça à la va comme je te
pousse chaque semaine ce que ses
conseillers lui disent peut-être de
faire regarder beaucoup de mobiles mais
milliards 0 pour le train 14 milliards
pour l'aéronautique mais airbus
s'apprête à mettre 4 rien dans l'achat
d'avions bombardier on a l'impression de
quelque chose qui n'est pas construit ni
planifié parce que ce n'est pas son
idéologie compte sur le marché voilà
alors après je lui dirais volontiers que
le satisfecit qu'il a fait sur l'état de
la france est assez surprenant parce que
il dit ouverte on a aussi bien fait
qu'ici maintenant pas mal d'endroits ils
très jeunes s'en inspirer et heredia la
déchirent notamment pour vous avez pu
voir que nous avions donc bien raison de
le harceler au début sur les masques et
les tests parce que c'est des pays où
les masques ont été distribués étaient
sont et épais que la mortalité est la
plus faible
l hexagone passe donc au vert les cafés
et restaurants peuvent rouvrir depuis ce
matin les écoles et collèges vont
accueillir de manière obligatoire les
élèves à partir du 22 juin emmanuel
macron à tourner donc officiellement la
page du premier acte de la crise du
coroner virus lui semblent très
satisfaits de sa gestion de la crise
évoque d'ailleurs une première victoire
est ce vraiment le cas c'est l'objet de
notre face à face ce soir
[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes en
direct avec benjamin amar enseignants
porte parole cgt du val de marne bonsoir
benjamin amar merci d'être avec nous et
à ses comptes et à ses côtés pour en
débattre denis demonpion éditorialiste
politique bonsoir denis demonpion merci
d'être avec nous alors on va commencer
par un sujet qui est cher à benjamin
amarin tous les élèves crèches écoles et
collèges vont reprendre les cours de
façon obligatoire à partir de lundi
prochain
c'est véritablement le retour à la vie
d'avant benjamin on imagine quelle a été
votre joie en découvrant cette annonce
d' emmanuel macron hier c'est le jeu là
sur la question de l'école
je pense que le prix nobel de
l'incompétence est incontestablement
attribué à la macro ni parce que la
rouvrir l'école pourquoi aller du 22
juin au 3 juillet dans les écoles et les
collèges
honnêtement franchement on est bon je
pense qu on est la risée de tout le
monde occidental on a un gouvernement
qui est en réalité court comme un poulet
sans tête
voilà je rappelle qu'en italie en
espagne qui ont été des clusters
similaire à la france eh bien on a
décidé une fois pour toutes de reporter
la rentrée en septembre
le débat était clos et voilà on
s'épargne et au moins ce débat inutile
en france c'est une saga incroyable et
le dernier le dernier épisode on se
disait conjoint ça y est les choses
étaient bouclés non non allez on va
rouvrir les écoles on va changer le
prône le protocole sanitaire pour
effectivement quoi huit ou neuf jours de
classe écoutez donc dans les écoles
primaires et les collèges où il va
falloir mettre en place un nouveau
protocole alléger je pense que les gens
vont se tirer les cheveux
mais enfin bon ça prouve encore une fois
je dirais le laval caen dira la
consistance et l'inconséquence de ce
gouvernement de nîmes deux motions
effectivement rouvrir les écoles pour
parfois huit jours parce que souvent les
les enfants non qu'école quatre jours ça
vous inspire quoi c'est un bon message
qu'on a envoyé aux français paie t il
qu'on sait très bien que depuis
vide la difficulté majeure n'est ce pas
c'était que faire des enfants en
difficulté à l'école s était une bonne
décision de confiner les laisser chez
eux c'est pas certain puisque il ya eu
toute une valse hésitation sur la
l'éventuelle contagion que pouvaient
propager les enfants il s'est avéré au
bout de deux mois que c'était moins
grave est que les enfants n'étaient pas
des vecteurs de contagion aussi sérieux
qu'on l'avait pensé d'abord donc
évidemment il ya eu un tâtonnement mais
est-ce que même le conseil scientifique
n'était pas grand clerc en la matière
donc c'est pas sûr pas non maintenant
que les enfants retournent à l'école
aujourd'hui c'est plutôt bien pourquoi
parce que il y en a beaucoup qui ont des
difficultés tous n'ont pas eu la chance
avec le télétravail des instituteurs de
pouvoir d'ailleurs j'ai des amis
instituteurs qui m'ont dit on en a perdu
en deux mois donc évidemment en une
semaine ou quinze jours ils ne vont pas
les rattraper mais c'est une bonne
manière de les ramener dans le giron de
l'école et peut-être de faciliter la
rentrée en septembre puisque voilà on
s'achemine quand même vers les vacances
et benjamin marc alors on va faciliter
la rentrée en septembre avec ses deux
semaines selon vous cette entité a
également précisé
je suis enseignant et je suis rentrée
dans l'enseignement pour lutter contre
le décrochage scolaire pour lutter
contre les inégalités scolaires et je ne
suis pas une exception
l'immense majorité de l'aîné collègues a
choisi ce métier pour cela mais cet
argument
cet argument de la lutte contre le
décrochage scolaire
mais honnêtement il est vous nourrir
parce que si l'on va en pleurer il
suffit de regarder que tous les
éditorialistes regarde les chiffres les
moyens alloués à la lutte contre le
décrochage scolaire depuis que monsieur
blanc caire ministre
eh bien ils verront tel fonds il faut
fondu comme neige au soleil
j'ai déjà
sur votre antenne ces chiffres là donc
cet argument mais c'est en réalité un
argument fallacieux
la seule raison c'est encore une fois
qu'il s'agit de faciliter le retour à
l'activité économique des paroles donc
on se dit que gagner dix jours d'école
c'est gagner dix jours de garderie sous
la question de la lutte contre les
inégalités c'est est l'alpha et l'oméga
de ce gouvernement
eh bien on n'aurait pas mis les deux ans
par exemple là on pourrait s'intéresser
à la façon dont on s'intéresse aux
parents il ya un dispositif mais les
dispositifs mis en place qui vont
consister à baisser la rémunération du
chômage partiel alors qu'on était déjà à
84% ya le fameux dispositif de larmes
qui va effectivement faire baisser à 70
% la rémunération des salariés
ce gouvernement il s'intéresse à la
lutte contre les inégalités comme les
confiseurs lui comme les confiseurs
lutte contre les caries et il s'agit d'
arrêter de prendre les gens pour des
idiots en leur disant qu en huit jours
on va lutter contre les inégalités
scolaires
il va falloir rattraper effectivement il
est vrai qu'on a perdu des élèves
pendant deux mois
et qu'est ce qui va se passer eh ben les
profs vont mettre les bouchées doubles
en septembre et c'est comme ça qu'on va
le régler et c'est l'épreuve qui vont
s'en charger
certainement pas monsieur blanc caire et
sa pseudo lutte contre les inégalités
scolaires
benjamin vous parliez économie le
président évoquait les préco vie d'un
longuement et la reconstruction
économique du pays chômage partiel des
entreprises dans tous les secteurs
l'état a mis près le rappel de 500
milliards d'euros sur la table ces trois
derniers mois je vous propose d'écouter
cet extrait d' emmanuel macron ces
dépenses se justifier et se justifie en
raison des circonstances exceptionnelles
que nous venons de vivre
mais elles viennent s'ajouter à notre
dette déjà existantes
nous ne financerons pas ses dépenses en
augmentant les impôts notre pays est
déjà l'un de ceux où la fiscalité est la
plus lourde
même si depuis trois ans nous avons
commencé à l'abaisser la seule réponse
est de bâtir un modèle économique
durable plus fort de travail et de
produire davantage pour ne pas dépendre
des autres alors pas d'augmentation
d'impôts promet emmanuel macron denis
demonpion peut-on le croire
écoutez les paroles les promesses
n'engagent que ceux qui les profèrent
n'est ce pas il ne voit pas comment le
président de la république un moment
donné pourra parcourir sinon à l'impôt
direct ce que faisait très bien françois
hollande son prédécesseur lui avait
choisi depuis qu'il est président de la
république un autre biais c'est à dire
d'augmenter les taxes
donc on ne voit pas le l'endettement de
la france de continuer éternellement
même si les critères de maastricht ont
été mis momentanément mis entre
parenthèses à un moment donné il faudra
payer l'addition
comment si le président de la république
fait le pari que l'économie va repartir
et la croissance aussi c'est loin d'être
acquis puisque on le voit bien depuis le
déconfinement le 11 mai et bien
l'activité a été très difficile à
reprendre
il ya toujours d'abord le virus n'est
pas vaincu donc et on ne sait pas si
demain il ne va pas à nouveau être d'une
virulence qui va obliger à prendre des
mesures drastiques en main du point de
vue sanitaire
donc de ce point de vue là il ya
toujours une espèce d'hésitation mais il
est vrai aussi que l'économie a été mise
totalement à plat et le chômage partiel
qui a été effectivement en europe le
plus comment dirais-je le plus large qui
soit puisque aucun autre pays en europe
à favoriser ce système à ce point là il
ya eu quand je lui rappelle quand même
12 millions de français ont bénéficié de
ça un moment donné il faut payer
l'addition
le président de la république a souligné
hier que tout ça n'empêcherait pas des
faillites des licenciements
donc il est devant un mur il n'a pas ses
vrais apporter de réponse à la manière
de faire face à ce mur et de l'escaladé
et il a juste exhorté les français
une fois encore à retrousser leurs
manches mais encore faut-il que
ils retroussent leurs manches dans un
contexte un petit peu plus précis que
celui qui a été dessiné hier
cependant en matière industrielle quand
il a parlé de rapatrier ou de développer
certains secteurs industriels marque
pardonnez moi de vous couper parce que
c'est un débat benjamin a marre sur
cette réponse d'emmanuel mc ren est
votre interlocuteur est également bon
d'abord première chose on se rend bien
compte comme que les libéraux avaient
tort parce que effectivement on a eu en
france le choix de d'impliquer l'état
dans l'économie
à un niveau inédit donc je suis prouve
bien que quand ça tangue
quand effectivement le navire est en
train de tanguay et bien c'est
l'intervention de l'état ce qui notre
bien que le système libéral et d'une
vacuité sans fond maintenant attention
parce que si on nous refait le même coup
qu'en 2008
on a eu une intervention massive de
l'état dans l'économie mais qu'ensuite
on a fait payer aux salariés et bien
quelque part c'est un véritable scandale
si l'on veut que le jour d'après ne
ressemble pas au jour d'avant empire
il faut réfléchir aux solutions parce
que encore une fois tu y es responsable
de la crise
cette prise elle a été provoquée encore
une fois par un système libéral qui
s'attaque aux ressources du vivant qui
saccagent les services publics et le
service public hospitalier a failli être
débordée qui affaiblit notre puissance
industrielle par des délocalisations
donc si on dit nos salariés c'est vous
qui allez payer les pots cassés alors
qu'ils ne sont responsables en rien de
cette crise
ça ne passera pas je rappelle que la
situation sociale est explosive et le
gouvernement le sait on n'a même pas
besoin de lui répéter
alors quand on entend la petite phrase
il va falloir travailler et produire
davantage et que l'on sait que depuis
plusieurs semaines les vautours léa
certain nombre de vautours avec une
mentalité de charognards nous disent
qu'il faut travailler plus si c'est ça
le sens de cette phrase sibylline
consistant à dire il faut produire et
travailler davantage
alors là vous leur maman doit savoir
qu'il est assis sur un baril de poudre
la cgt refusera refusera catégoriquement
que l'on baisse les salaires
ou que l'on augmente le temps de travail
les accords de performance collective
qui sont mises en place et qui consiste
effectivement à faire baisser les
salaires avec un chantage insupportable
à l'emploi je peux vous garantir qu'on
va en faire une bataille cruciale
il y a des solutions il y a des
solutions je veux dire on a toujours
pourquoi ce que ce gouvernement ne
décide pas c'est le moment ou jamais de
mener une bataille nationale contre
l'évasion fiscale
y'en a des milliards à attraper je
rappelle qu'alors qu'on nous dit que le
cac 40 est en berne est en hibernation
je vous rappelle que axa qui refusent de
rembourser les restes et restaurateurs
et les commerçants qui ont été confinés
distribuer 1,7 milliard de dividendes
aux actionnaires total 7 milliards
sanofi 4 milliards donc encore une fois
si on veut s'occuper de la fiscalité n'y
a pas de problème à ont présenté la
fiscalité on peut mettre en place une
fiscalité sur les dividendes une
taxation
une manière de taxer enfin le le le
capital financier
il ya de quoi faire glas de la marge
merci en tout cas tous les deux on
arrive déjà à la fin de ce débat il ya
plusieurs thèmes qu'on voulait aborder
mais voilà en tout cas vous vous avez
donné votre opinion sur les grandes
mesures merci benjamin marc denis deux
montants d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france et on en vient à la course
au vaccin contre le coc u19 qui fait
rage plusieurs laboratoires sont
aujourd'hui en lice pour la découverte
de la fameuse molécule qui préviendra
qui préservera plus tôt l'humanité du
virus avec peut-être des techniques
révolutionnaires mais aussi des
questions sur la fiabilité de leurs
études les explications de guillaume à
rossi en ces temps de pandémie une
attention exceptionnelle est porté à
l'actualité scientifique et tout
particulièrement à la recherche d'un
vaccin
ce précieux traitement qui
transformerait la menace du coc vie de
19 et ses conséquences en un lointain
souvenir et la star pharmaceutiques du
moment c'est moderna therapeutics une
société américaine de biotechnologie
d'une dizaine d'années installé à boston
et dirigé cocorico par le français
stéphane bancel
un ancien cadre du laboratoire lyonnais
biomnis yeux et 6 modern a fait autant
parler d'elle c'est parce qu'elle a
annoncé il y a quelques jours avoir
finalisé le protocole de la troisième
phase de l'essai clinique d'un
5 contre le coronavirus la troisième et
donc dernière phase avant de soumettre
son produit aux autorités de
réglementation le vaccin développé par
moderna le mrn à 12,73 est comme son nom
indique un vaccin à arn messagers soit
un type de traitement encore jamais
éprouvé jusque là sur l'homme
si cette solution s'avérait être la
bonne elle ouvrirait la porte à une
nouvelle ère de la vaccination
problème il semblerait que moderna aille
un peu vite en besogne
le 18 mai dernier la société annonçait
les résultats positifs selon elle de la
première phase d'essais cliniques de son
vaccin
sauf que les données étaient très
lacunaire et ne concernait que huit
patients sur les 45 tester la phase iii
quant à elle est déjà annoncée alors que
la phase ii n'est même pas terminée un
calendrier très serré donc pour le
développement d'un vaccin qui a commencé
début janvier et qui ne plaît guère à
certains spécialistes les résultats
scientifiques doivent pouvoir être
examiné en détail par des pairs pour
tester leur validité lusage de
communiqués de presse surtout s'il ne
précède pas immédiatement une
publication scientifique est une
pratique nouvelle qui met à mal éthique
de la recherche moderna n'est pas la
seule entreprise de la santé à chercher
un traitement contre le coronavirus au 9
juin dernier selon le ms les
laboratoires du monde entier plancher
sur quelque 136 vaccins potentiels dont
dix sont actuellement en phase d'essais
cliniques
une course effrénée à la recherche d'un
traitement qui revêt un enjeu financier
colossal moderna a déjà reçu 4 183
millions de dollars de subventions pour
accélérer le développement de son vaccin
et mieux encore le jour de l'annoncé des
premiers résultats sa valeur en bourse
s'envolait de 30% et quelques jours plus
tard modern a levé 1,34 milliard de
dollars sur les marchés pour financer le
produit miracle
alors est-ce que moderna therapeutics
livrera bien un vaccin en janvier 2021
soit l'objectif fixé par washington
ce qui est certain c'est que le labo de
bust maîtrise sa communication et c'est
la mettre à profit les 18 et 19 mai ses
dirigeants on
du des centaines de milliers d'actions
pour des dizaines de millions de dollars
de bénéfices un succès financier
purement spéculatif si l'on en croit
bruno pitard directeur de recherche au
cnrs la pandémie crée des opportunités
et moderna est un champion qui suscite
beaucoup d'espoir celui d'avoir un
vaccin est celui que les titres achetés
valence 8 plus cher mais dans la biotech
c'est toujours comme ça c'est une bulle
moderna surf sur le fait qu'elle mène la
course pour le grand public comme pour
les professionnels qu'il s'agisse de
moderna de la première étude du dr house
ou de la récente publication du land 7
il semble urgent de prendre son temps
lorsqu'il s'agit de santé et ne pas
céder à l'illusion du remède miracle et
pour en parler de soi vous avec violaine
guérin immunologie et semant du
collectif kobe 19 laissons les médecins
à prescrire bonsoir à violaines guérin
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france on vient d'entendre un moderne
n'a therapeutics qui parle de résultats
encourageants on peut se poser la
question est ce vraiment le cas quand on
sait que seuls mes patients ont reçu
deux doses de vaccin ont développé des
anticorps neutralisants entre le virus
lors s'est-il huit patients le 18 mai
parce que j'avais entendu la
communication directe du directeur
général donc probablement que kylie a eu
plus de d'administration en revanche
l'étude de phase 1 effectivement semble
être très compressé les patients a
priori qui ont commencé à recevoir les
doses sont jeunes puisqu'ils ont entre
18 et 55 ans et il semblerait que le
laboratoire ait décidé de faire d'autres
administrations avec des personnes plus
âgées ce qui serait cohérent puisque on
veut en particulier de lors desquelles
vaccination surtout sera une pathologie
de type coronavirus protéger des
personnes âgées avec des comorbidités
donc
on a l'impression effectivement qu'on va
un peu vite dans tout cela c'est la
constante qu'on observe sur cette crise
du cornât virus
il y à des enjeux financiers majeurs des
laboratoires et en particulier comme l'a
dit votre collègue savent très bien
manipulé en particulier des dépôts de
biotech manipuler les annonces pour
faire bouger les cours de bourse et
c'est ce qui sous-tend ensuite les
invités des gros investissements dont
vous avez parlé
donc tout ça se questionne beaucoup
parce que effectivement normalement on
va plutôt communiquer quand on a des
résultats certains comment justement
vous expliquer ce côté on va trop vite
parce que c'est quand même quelque chose
qui est relayé également par la presse
on sait quel point c'est très très long
de trouver un vaccin et là on l'on
présente cela comme une quasi solutions
il y a énormément de laboratoires qui
travaillent sur le sujet et et on veut à
l'évidence est le premier à communiquer
parce qu'il ya toujours un effet
extrêmement positif d'être le premier à
faire émerger une solution thérapeutique
donc c'est un petit peu cela on
s'aperçoit dans l'historique de de ce
laboratoire qui a eu beaucoup de
communication comme ça en a qui sont
arrivés ils sont arrivés à l'oser
beaucoup de fonds avec
je n'ai je n'ai pas réussi à trouver
exactement des produits qu'ils ont
finalement commercialisé avec des
autorisations de mise sur le marché en
tout cas il m'a pas sur le marché
français à ma connaissance et ils
avancent beaucoup en faisant ses
communications mais ce qu'elle prof
d'été des laboratoires de
biotechnologies ou ou de du domaine de
des télécommunications de la tis et
c'est un peu comme ça qu'ils font qu'ils
avancent on sait évidemment la
communication vous l'avez très bien
expliqué c'est très important mais on
sait aussi voilà que les agréments sont
très difficiles à avoir que c'est très
long lit tout le temps les vaccins sont
sont difficiles long il faut voilà les
tester avoir les autorisations pourquoi
cela irait plus vite cette fois ci selon
vous parce qu'il ya la pression de la
pandémie
donc on se trouve dans des cas de
situation entre guillemets d'urgence où
on peut avoir des procédures accélérées
mais ces procédures accélérées sont
souvent extrêmement dangereuse parce
qu'effectivement on va trop vite donc on
va trop vite sous plein de plans sous la
recherche de doses puisque là on
s'aperçoit qu'il ya eu trois doses
testées 25 100 et 250 microgrammes dans
ce qui a été communiqué en tout cas par
le laboratoire donc sondé recherche de
doses entre 500 et 250 qui arrive
peut-être pu avoir d'autres paliers 1
donc ça déjà c'est c'est important à
prendre conscience on va souvent trop
vite et pourtant la recherche de dos
c'est quelque chose de crucial
et puis l évaluation des événements
indésirables de ce que j'ai pu le voir
dans ce qui a été communiqué par le
laboratoire sur la dose de 250
microgrammes
il ya eu quand même pas mal d'effets
indésirables donc là on en a pas parlé
non plus donc tout cela normalement
prendre prendre du temps et c'est un
petit peu choquant puisque bon vous
savez que moi je fais partie du
collectif laissons les médecins à
prescrire et qui
fait conscience qu'il y a dans cette
pathologie des solutions thérapeutiques
même si on n'a pas voulu beaucoup en
parler donc c'est certain que des
vaccins sont intéressants mais on
devrait effectivement prendre tout le
temps de faire ce qu'on appelle un
développement correct
on a beaucoup parlé ensemble justement
de l'hydroxyde chloroquine ce soir les
etats-unis retirent l'autorisation
d'urgence de cette molécule pour le coc
vide
19 comment vous vous l'expliquer ce
petit rebondissement
on est très surpris de 2 comment la
crise se passe parce que il y a à
l'évidence des intérêts pharmaceutiques
à la fois sur les vaccins comme on vient
d'en parler mais également sur des
thérapeutiques
et puis toujours cette problématique du
protocole hydroxy chloroquine
azithromycine qui n'a pas été très
suivie à grande échelle dans une phase
précoce à part les publications dont on
a déjà parlé
et là il ya des enjeux un petit peu
curieux avec les états qui se
précipitent qui on a entendu parler de
la france qui a signé un investissement
pour un vaccin partenariat avec quatre
pays européens alors qu'on essaye de
faire l'europe de la médecine
il ya plein de plaine précipitation et
plein d'enjeux je pense financiers plus
que totalement rationnelle et
scientifique et donc on subissent la
mairie complexe beaucoup en tout cas on
aura compris cette complexité
surtout la prudence aussi vous affichez
merci violaine dira en avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france merci à
vous donc quelques instants rester avec
nous nous parlerons de l'europe c'est
une semaine décisive et diplomatiques
entre négociations post break site
entretien avec le secrétaire d'état
américain et conseil européen ce
vendredi et puis direction les états
unis ou la mort attentat d'un
afro américain tué par un policier blanc
a ravivé la colère des manifestants
contre le racisme
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on a une idée d'augmentation
ou pas dessine ici aujourd'hui en france
l'écho et les violences n'existait avant
le confinement et pendant ce compliment
c'est vrai qu'il ya sept ce cadre
lecture les dos des féminicides a plus
que j'étais pas doublé mais bien monté
forcément on n'a pas encore tous les
chiffres officiels c'est très difficile
gros n'est jamais n'est jamais loin
finalement c'est le confinement dans le
confinement
cela veut dire qu'il ya huit clos au
sein des foyers
et forcément donc les femmes victimes de
violences de nombreux endroits à 3
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
ça fait maintenant plusieurs jeu direct
et ses nus presque que la france ou
financent sa recherche et son
enseignement supérieur à quoi est-ce que
vous attribuez ce manque de moyens c'est
un un problème politique au sens où ça
serait pas devant le projet politique
la grande cherche n'a pas la place
qu'elles devraient avoir parce que la
recherche est un élément central dans la
prise en compte et très très grand défi
auquel nous sommes et en particulier le
défi qui paye ses conséquences et
notamment les pandémies
là c'est la première mais qui va y en
avoir d'autres
il faut qu'ils aient une prise de
conscience collective vraiment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur rt france 20h30
heure française les gouvernements
européens critiqués pour leur gestion de
la crise sanitaire en france le
procureur de paris annonce l'ouverture
d'une vaste enquête préliminaire pour
des accusations d'homicide involontaire
ou encore de mise en danger de la vie
d'autrui l'italie l'espagne le royaume
uni les ministres sont également pointés
du doigt tour d'horizon en images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
e
m
[Musique]
relancer des négociations dans l'impasse
c'est l'objectif de la réunion qui s'est
déroulée aujourd'hui entre les
dirigeants des vingt sept états membres
et le premier ministre britannique
c'est la première fois depuis le brésil
que boris johnson prend part
personnellement aux discussions l'union
européenne et le royaume uni sont venus
de donner un nouvel élan aux
négociations posera exceed dans la passé
comme je les dis aux trois présidents
mettez un petit goût dans votre moteur
car c'est clairement ce dont a besoin
d'angleterre est ce que nos amis de
l'union européenne ont besoin de
comprendre
nous ne pouvons pas faire participer la
cour de justice européenne dans ce pays
nous ne pouvons pas avoir un système où
nous sommes obligés d'obéir aux
règlements de l'union européenne alors
que nous ne faisons pas partie mais nous
devons donner un coup de boost aux
négociations et je suis très contente
ursula von der leyen
le président de la commission charles
michel et le président du conseil est
d'avis de cinsault dit le président du
parlement européen soit d'accord ils ont
signé une bonne déclaration pour nous
faire avancer
nous avons pris note de la décision du
royaume uni de ne pas demander de
prolongation de la période de transition
la période de transition prendra donc
fin le 31 décembre 2020 conformément aux
dispositions de l'accord de retrait
quatre cycles ont été menées à bien et
des textes ont été échangées malgré les
défis posés par la pandémie de kobe 19
nous avons néanmoins convenu qu'un
nouvel élan était nécessaire nous avons
soutenu les plans convenu par les
négociateurs en chef en vue
d'intensifier les pourparlers en juillet
et de créer les conditions les plus
propices à la conclusion et à la
ratification d'un accord avant la fin de
cela devrait inclure si possible de
trouver rapidement une compréhension des
principes qui sous-tendent tout accord
nous avons souligné notre intention de
travailler dur pour établir une relation
qui servirent
les intérêts des citoyens de l'union et
du royaume uni nous avons également
confirmé notre engagement en faveur de
la mise en oeuvre intégrale et dans les
délais de l'accord de retrait la journée
décidément riche pour l'union européenne
sous pression constante des etats-unis
sur les volets diplomatiques économiques
bruxelles a mis sur la table ces
contentieux avec washington les
ministres des affaires étrangères de
l'ue eux se sont réunis dans la journée
par visioconférence avec mike pompéo le
secrétaire d'état américain
malgré des sujets de discussion houleuse
le chef de la diplomatie européenne a
réaffirmé sa volonté d'une coopération
transatlantique une esthétique dialogue
qui nous avons engagé un dialogue
stratégique avec mike pompeo sur nos
relations et sur des questions clés de
politique étrangère à la fois pour
l'union européenne et les etats unis
comme vous le savez il est inutile de le
souligner mais permettez moi quand même
de le faire le partenariat
transatlantique est l'un des piliers
clefs de l'ordre mondial et aujourd'hui
lors de la réunion les acteurs affirme
l'engagement de l'union européenne à
poursuivre cette coopération
transatlantique étroite
peut-être que nous ne sommes pas
d'accord sur tout mais notre attachement
à la coopération transatlantique est
plus fort que jamais et ça c est pour en
parler nous sommes avec claude longchamp
maison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir sur deux
blanchemaison merci d'être avec nous une
nouvelle semaine décisive donc pour
l'europe avec les négociations post
break site peut-on s'attendre à une
avancée dans ce dossier ben je crois
qu'aujourd'hui boris johnson a fait
irruption dans l'arène de la négociation
pour la définition du régime définitif
de coopération entre l'union européenne
et la grande bretagne
il ya un an et il ya quelques mois
l'année dernière il avait fait irruption
de la même manière dans la négociation
de l'accord de divorce
et puis on avait finalement trouvé un
accord alors aujourd'hui je crois
beaucoup dépend de lui
pour qu'un accord soit trouvé dans les
prochains mois il faudra laisser un peu
de temps à la fin de l'année pour que
les parlements nationaux puissent le
ratifier si boris johnson a décidé qu'il
y aurait un accord et cet accord est
techniquement possible
les spécialistes peuvent négocier un
accord sur le libre échange avec des
indicateurs sur les conditions
équitables de concurrence en matière
fiscale en matière sociale en matière
environnementale puisque c'est ce que
demande l'union européenne le maintien
de droits de pêche que l'union
européenne avait dans les eaux
britanniques est évidemment aussi très
important les britanniques veulent que
ce soit un accord annuel donc remettre
en question chaque année les choses
ce qui n'est pas acceptable pour l'union
européenne il faut donc trouver un
compromis et puis sur la cour de justice
européenne
il serait quand même légitime que
lorsque le désaccord porte sur
l'interprétation de règles de l'union
européenne ce soit la cour de justice
qui donne son interprétation
et puis on peut trouver un arrangement
pour que les tribunaux britanniques est
aussi leur mot à dire dans le règlement
des litiges
mais si boris johnson a décidé d'avoir
un odile parce que finalement il a été
élu sur un pire état de forme purement
politique sortir le plus vite possible
de l'union européenne et peut-être dans
les conditions plus ou moins dramatique
si c'est ça son choix politique
évidemment il n'y aura pas d'accord
parce qu'à ce moment-là ministre qui
représente et qui négocie avec monsieur
variés évidemment ne bougeront pas et
l'union européenne ne bougera pas non
plus donc actuellement je crois que
c'est ben johnson qui a les cartes en
main un accord est possible ça dépend de
lui
emmanuel macron est donc attendu jeudi
au royaume uni il s'entretiendra avec
boris johnson quel est l'enjeu de cette
visite aux
d'abord le président de république
française se met dans les pas du général
de gaulle puisqu'il va d'abord à londres
pour le 80e anniversaire de l'appel du
18 juin du général de gaulle donc je
crois que c'est pour lui très important
pour les britanniques aussi puisque
churchill avait accueilli le général de
gaulle et l'avait autorisé à lancer cet
appel à la bbc donc ce sera un moment
d'histoire d'histoire commune très
importante entre la france et le
royaume-uni de grande-bretagne
d'ailleurs à l'époque churchill avait
proposé dans l'urgence une fusion des
deux exécutifs de façon à pouvoir
continuer le combat contre l'allemagne
nazie ce qui avait été refusé par le
gouvernement français à l'époque alors
par ailleurs évidemment ils se il
discutera avec boris johnson et
certainement
ils discuteront des points à dur de la
négociation sur le futur régime de
coopération entre l'union européenne et
et la grande bretagne et il est probable
que leurs discussions contribuera à
éclaircir le sujet et à faciliter la
recherche d'une solution est un autre
sujet qui est important pour la france
et la coopération militaire bilatérale
avec la grande bretagne
il ne faut pas l'oublier la rencontre
entre les ministères des affaires
étrangères et le secrétaire d'état
américain mike pompéo à présent une
franche explication est nécessaire
oui nécessaires et d'ailleurs pas très
amical parce que monsieur pompéo a
rappelé que les états unis tenait aux
liens transatlantiques à la coopération
transatlantique
on pourrait parfois en douter en
écoutant les sorties intempestives du
président américain
mais monsieur pompéo a voulu rassurer et
du côté des européens bien sûr des
questions ont été posées
on a dit que on ne cherchait pas du côté
européen
une confrontation directe frontale avec
la chine
on a dit qu'on n'accepterait pas que
l'europe n'accepterait pas
l'incorporation de colonies israéliennes
de la vallée du jourdain dans l'état
d'israël
donc il ya un certain nombre de points
de désaccord mais on peut faire
confiance à monsieur josette borel le
haut représentant pour les affaires
étrangères et la sécurité européenne qui
est un vieux routier de la diplomatie
puisqu'il a été mise affaires étrangères
espagnol après avoir été puis à un peu
plus longtemps par la précision du
parlement européen donc je crois que ces
conversations ont été utiles elles ont
permis de faire le point de part et
d'autre de montrer qu'il y avait
beaucoup de points communs notamment
dans la lutte contre le terrorisme
et là je crois que d'ailleurs le
ministre français tenait à faire part de
de son point de vue notamment dans la
vitre sur les turcs contre le terrorisme
en afrique dans lequel la france prend
une part tout à fait particulière et
jusqu'à présent avec l'appui des moyens
logistiques américain alors ce vendredi
un club blanchemaison les membres du
conseil européen se réuniront par
vidéoconférence que peut-on en attendre
je crois qu'ils vont se jauger
c'est un peu tôt pour en attendre un
accord d'autant plus qu'on a un autre
conseil européen est prévu en juillet et
celui ci devrait se réunir avec la
présence physique des différents chefs
d'état et de gouvernement et pour
vraiment négocier il faut qu'il puisse y
avoir des interruptions de séance des
réunions bilatérales
des réunions secrètes etc il faut donc
que tous les chefs d'état gouvernement
soit sur place ça ce sera pour juillet
mais en attendant la réunion ii
la fin de la semaine de vendredi
prochain est très importante puisqu'elle
va permettre d'évaluer un peu les forces
en présence
la commission a fait une proposition 725
milliards d'euros dont 500 milliards de
prêts 250 milliards de dollars dont 500
milliards de dons est évidemment ce qui
est demandé au conseil européen c'est
d'autoriser la commission à faire un
emprunt de 725 milliards d'euros sur les
marchés financiers
évidemment c'est sans précédent car la
commission n'a jamais emprunté de sommes
importantes
donc cette autorisation qui est demandé
et on sait que quatre étapes qu'on a
qualifié d'état frugaux sont très
réservés
les pays bas là c'est l'autriche le
danemark et la suède
mais ils ont perdu leur leader leur
leader c'était l'allemagne
or l'allemagne s'est ralliée à la
proposition française et soutient la
proposition de la commission
par conséquent ils vont se sentir un peu
seul alors bien sûr il faudra sans doute
leur donner des garanties
peut-être y aura-t-il un peu plus de
près un peu moins de dons peut-être
aussi il y aura-t-il des garanties sur
d'autres sujets puisqu'il ya un autre
volet dans cette négociation et le
budget de l'union européenne pour les
chaînes les sept prochaines années de
2021 à 2027 un milliard cent millions
d'euros et évidemment ce qui est prévu
c'est que l'emprunt 2,725 milliards
d'euros viennent abonder ce budget c'est
à dire viennent l'augmenter bien entendu
et ensuite la fée la commission qui
propose chaque année les l'utilisation
du reste du budget il ya bien entendu
les règles de remboursement qui feront
aussi l'objet d'un débat ardue parce que
les quatre états dits frugaux ne veulent
pas de mutualisation de la dette mais
les choses ont beaucoup évolué en
quelques mois à cause de la crise du
corps la virus et puis parce qu'il ya un
changement de génération chez les
dirigeants et aujourd'hui je pense qu'il
est possible d'envisager un accord sur
ce paquet durant l'été et ce paquet je
blague précisé s'ajoutent aux 550
milliards d'euros ont déjà été décidées
par les mines et des finances et
s'ajoutent bien entendu
actions de la banque centrale européenne
qui elle-même a ouvert les vannes en
rachetant des obligations des états
membres qui en ont besoin et ceci
jusqu'à hauteur de 1 milliard cent
millions d'euros entre maintenant et
dans un an
c'est donc des moyens considérables qui
sont mobilisés et je pense que la leaf
et amant voit l'enjeu économique
chacun a un intérêt majeur à sauver
l'unicité du marché unique est également
à sauver la zone euro
merci blanche l'autre blanchemaison
d'avoir été avec nous avoir apporté
votre analyse aux états unis à présent
nuit plus calme atlanta deux jours après
la mort d'un afro américain abattu par
un agent de police lors de son
arrestation un nouveau drame qui a
ravivé la colère des manifestants alors
qu'ils aient un donald trump célébrer
son soixante quatorzième anniversaire
des centaines de personnes se sont
rassemblées devant le trump
international hotel à new york pour
protester contre la brutalité policière
et les discriminations raciales
rassemblement également devant la maison
blanche et dans d'autres villes des
états unis et du monde écoutez la
réaction
gérald grieg à vos cartes dans cette
affaire la loi en géorgie est clair on
ne peut pas recourir à la force létale
en riposte à l' usage de la force non
létales je crois que les deux policiers
seront inculpés de meurtre j'ai parlé au
procureur dans cette affaire qui a lancé
son enquête indépendante séparément de
celle de l'antenne géorgienne du fbi
yagg
les gens doivent comprendre qu'en
géorgie les forces de l'ordre n'incarne
pas le droit la justice est rendue dans
les tribunaux et l'on ne peut pas user
de la force létale en riposte à l' usage
de la force non létales il y a eu cette
affaire tennessee contre garner dans
lequel la cour suprême des etats-unis a
confirmé ce principe
je crois que cette affaire sera examinée
par la cour supérieure du comté de
fulton et que les deux policiers seront
inculpés de meurtre retour en images sur
les diverses manifestations quatre coins
du monde
[Applaudissements]
je l'aï compris tard
[Musique]
non
pour nous c'était important de venir car
il faut un beau futur pour mes enfants
pour nous un monde sans racisme et qui
s'engage pour le climat
[Musique]
m
pas certain
[Musique]
nous protestons pour soutenir le
mouvement black l'armateur et contre le
système raciste aux états unis dont l'un
des symptômes et la brutalité policière
et pour évoquer la situation aux états
unis nous sommes en direct depuis
athlètes avec abel swan journaliste
d'investigation c'est notre rubrique vu
de l'extérieur ce soit bonsoir vençois
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
fons vous êtes un précisément à atlanta
quelle est l'atmosphère sur place est ce
que la colère et est retombé alors on
nous parle en somme cela est un peu
retors des mises à jour vu beaucoup de
manifestations lors du week end
le restaurant wendy's a été incendiée ce
même restaurant où brian cox a fait face
à la police et la lecture je l'achète à
a démissionné ce week end et la maire de
la ville a dit qu'elle n'avait pas
demandé cette émission mais en tout cas
elle a démissioné bien qu'elle
continuera à travailler pour la
municipalité
la colère est légèrement retombé mais
cela ne fait qu'ajouter au sentiment
général de frustration du contre la
brutalité policière
cela fait pas mal de temps maintenant
que je suis le sujet est beaucoup de
personnes disent que c'est très
différent du cas georges flop parce que
monsieur s'est affronté la police il a
volé un taser il s'est battu et il a
tiré avec ses tailleurs sur la police
certaines personnes disent que c'est
différent mais pas les manifestants pour
le rachat de brousse n'aurait jamais dû
se retrouver dans cette situation il
était ivre dans sa voiture il a proposé
de rentrer chez lui à pied on ne lui a
pas permis de le faire il s est
effectivement de se battre et de se
dégager pour rentrer chez lui mais on
lui a tiré dans le dos et c'est donc un
autre exemple d'une l'usagé excessif de
la force
justement quand on connaît le contexte
tellement explosive on se demande
comment effectivement ce genre
d'événements peut arriver à nouveau on
peut survenir
il n'ya pas justement un côté on se dit
la police qu'il faut vraiment être
rigoureux en ce moment en cette période
particulièrement et ne pas commettre ce
genre de bavure
surprenant donc cette affaire c'est que
si on regarde les vidéos comme je lé
fais mais une caméra embarquée le web et
qui montre à chaque box parlant avec la
police si on regarde la discussion
reichardt books n'est pas véritable il
ne se dispute pas la conversation et
très polis les policiers eux mêmes sont
polis il leur explique qu'il ya
effectivement il a bu que sa chère fille
juste à côté et qu'ils rentrent à tout
simplement à pied chez lui qui est ce
que cela ne lui pose aucun problème
et lorsqu'ils essayent de l'arrêter
c'est à ce moment là qu'il essaye de se
dégager
donc c'est un fait une escale est
extrêmement rapide entre la police et
monsieur books qui mène justement à
asson sa mort crèche à bursa à tirer
avec un taser et peut-être que s'il
avait été tué alors peut-être que s'il
avait été touché alors ça lui aurait été
tellement j'ai aimé rien dans la vidéo
semble indiquer que cela allait arriver
rien du tout rien dans cette vidéo on
indique que ces policiers étaient en
danger que leur vie était en danger
en tout cas au moment où à chaque boucle
s'enfuit donc c'est la cause de toute
cette frustration il ya des lignes
politiques très clair les personnes en
en faveur des réductions dupuch aidé à
politis est un exemple du genre de
choses qu'il faut éviter et les
personnes qui sont contre cette idée de
démontrer la police disent non les
policiers se sont bien comportés et s'il
avait pu se défendre et bien ça aurait
été une bonne chose
donc c'est un moment supplémentaire et
c'est là qu'on trace une ligne
et on ne parle plus de ce cas
particulier on ne se demande plus est ce
que cette personne méritait de mourir
on se dit plutôt très politiquement ce
qu'il faudrait faire avec la police en
général vis-à-vis notamment des vies
noir alors le procureur du district de
falcon a indiqué que son bureau à les
décider à d'ici le milieu de la semaine
des poursuites engagées contre ces
policiers est ce que la nature de ces
poursuites va être déterminante est ce
que c'est le genre de décision qui peut
justement exacerber les tensions au
contraire les apaiser
il s'agit de poursuites civiles
alors c'est une chose mais s il y à des
poursuites pénales contre lui la junte
police c'est encore autre chose
l'officier a été offert et c'est déjà
fait l'autre a été mis en service
administratif mais la question c'est
vraiment y aura-t-il effectivement un
véritable procès pénal et est ce que cet
agent de police se retrouvera devant les
tribunaux les deux parties discutent de
ce problème et il ya toujours cette
ligne dans le sable
certaines personnes disent non il ne
devrait pas y avoir de procès et
d'autres qui disent eh bien écoutez
voici un policier qui a tué à un homme
mort est un homme noir il faut pas qu'il
s'en sorte
pour le moment nous ne cherchons pas les
solutions pour notre problème nous
entrons dans un débat assez vain nous
avons choisi nos postures nos positions
et il n'y a plus vraiment de débat on ne
se demande plus comment pourrait
alimenter et à améliorer la situation
notre sujet je voulais aborder avec vous
pour cette rubrique vu de l'extérieur en
france et des rumeurs sur l'état de
santé de donald trump est parue vous
savez un diminué lors d'une cérémonie
militaire à ce que c'est un sujet dont
on parle beaucoup aux états unis qu'est
ce qui se dit effectivement certaines
personnes s'inquiètent de l'état de
santé du président pense qu'il commence
à fatiguer avec les problèmes
économiques qui se portaient très bien
jusqu'à la crise d'une coronavirus avec
le problème des manifestations dans tout
le pays et avec le taux de popularité du
président qui est très très bas donc
effectivement il semble en payer le prix
et on se demande s'il pourra soutenir le
tenir le coup au moins physiquement
sinon émotionnellement parce
qu'effectivement il semble très fatigué
mais il serait difficile d'imaginer que
cela ne fait-il grippe a merci beaucoup
benz one journée les investigations
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france pour vu de l'extérieur ce soir
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous reviendrons sur les manifestations
et des policiers la colère ne retombe
pas alors que les protestataires sont
mécontents anglais fins d'utilisation de
la méthode de l'étranglement annoncé par
christophe castaner la semaine dernière
et par assuré par les mots du président
de la république
et puis nous évoquerons les soignants
eux aussi en colère à l'appel de
plusieurs organisations syndicales une
journée nationale de mobilisation des
personnels des hôpitaux est prévue
demain
[Musique]
m
tous les secteurs de la culture sont
sont touchés la musique le cinéma le
théâtre elle les musées avec trois mois
de non activité où les billetteries sont
à l'arrêt l'impact financier est énorme
ce sera leur démarche sous conditions 1
avec port du masque obligatoire
distanciation physique gestion des flux
de ce que nous attendons c'est
effectivement la possibilité de rouvrir
sans ces mesures barrières le plus vite
possible
on retrouvera pas le marché que nous
avons quitté en 2021
il faudra reconstruire le marché ça
prendra plusieurs mois voire plusieurs
années
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française d'autres affirment
même que nous ne sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
l'écologie ce n'est pas de la politique
dernier rapport du giec sur les océans
comme ça fout les jetons
on est dans une espèce de déni collectif
on ne veut pas croire ce qu'on sait et
scientifique parle quand même de la
sixième extinction de la vie sur terre
et à d'autres experts qui contestent
leur usine en russie
personne non non c'est pas vrai il ya
des crimes à tous et non ce n'est pas
rien à part des gens qui ne sont pas des
chercheurs qui parlent que la presse met
en avant parce que il faut que du débat
le ya plus de débat aujourd'hui il n'y a
plus aucun débat ce changement
climatique et on va vers une vraie par
une catastrophe ou 20 vers une vraie
catastrophe et on est incapable d'en
prendre conscience
mais ce n'est pas des pessimistes de
comprendre ce qui va arriver pour moi je
pense qu'on est comme une guerre
aujourd'hui on est entré en guerre
contre nos façons vu et l'ennemi y en a
pas des demies l'ennemi c'est nous
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coût politique a jamais été obligé
de dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui comptent la haine en soi vient
de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche plus
extrêmes
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande île de review
[Musique]
d
bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour cette deuxième heure d'émission il
est 21h heure de paris tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité de ce lundi 15
juin
les forces de l'ordre loin d'être
apaisées après les propos d' emmanuel
macron plusieurs centaines de policiers
ont manifesté hier soir sur l'esplanade
du trocadéro à paris et ont à nouveau
déposé leurs menottes en signe de
protestation
un autre rassemblement a eu lieu en
milieu de journée devant l'hôtel de
police de versailles
du côté des soignants également la
colère ne retombe pas à l'appel de
plusieurs organisations syndicales une
journée nationale de mobilisation des
personnels des hôpitaux a été décrétée
pour demain malgré le ségur de la santé
lancée par le gouvernement ils réclament
une revalorisation des salaires ou bien
encore l'arrêt de toutes les fermetures
d'établissements de service et de lille
tous les regards sont à nouveau tournés
vers la chine
un nouveau rebond du virus à pékin en
plus de 104 sont confirmés selon
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
et avec ces chiffres c'est la peur d'une
deuxième vague qui ressurgit pékin et je
cite en guerre contre le kobe 19 confine
des quartiers entiers et referme ses
sites culturels et sportifs à
beyrouth durci le ton après plusieurs
jours de manifestations dans le pays
mettent en garde contre les actes de
vandalisme les autorités promettent
également des arrestations alors que le
liban est au bord de l'effondrement
économique la semaine dernière
rassemblement et blocages de routes
avaient secoué le pays
[Musique]
alors que les forces de l'ordre sont
accusés de racisme et de violences et
derniers jours par certains pour le chef
de l'état policiers et gendarmes mérite
le soutien de la puissance publique et
la reconnaissance de la nation
mais ce soutien n'a visiblement pas
convaincu dans les rangs des forces de
l'ordre hier soir des centaines de
policiers se sont rassemblés sur
l'esplanade du trocadéro
un nouveau rassemblement a eu lieu en
milieu de journée devant l'hôtel de
police de versailles les précisions sur
place de notre reporter katia technique
les rapides mots de soutien des manuels
macron lors de son allocution hier soir
n'ont pas rassuré les policiers bien au
contraire il souhaite que le ministre de
l'intérieur christophe castaner
reviennent sur les propos qu'il a tenus
la semaine dernière et certains
souhaitent qu'il quitte le ministère
s'était un peu le sens de cette action
organisée à 13h30 devant l'hôtel de
police de versailles devant lequel je me
trouve une centaine de policiers du
département sont venus déposer au sol
leur brassard et leurs menottes
une manière d'affirmer leur opposition
notamment au gouvernement le mouvement
de contestation au sein de la police
montrent les actions commencées dès
jeudi et encore hier soir des centaines
de policiers se sont rejoint sur la
place du trocadéro des policiers de
terrain qui ont contesté ce gouvernement
et ce dans un climat où les
manifestations contre le racisme dans la
police ou les violences policières se
multiplient en france et pour reparler
de cette colère des forces de l'ordre
nous sommes avec et jean-pierre
colombiès par parole de l'association
police union des policiers nationaux
indépendants
bonsoir monsieur colombiès merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france à ses
côtés françois bersani de l'unité sgp
police 78 bonsoir à vous aussi
françois bersani d'être avec merci à
vous aussi d'être avec vous voulez je
dire
quelle est votre réaction après ce
discours d' emmanuel macron les
policiers aujourd'hui ont besoin de
preuves d'amour
il ya eu des déclarations d'amour hier
soir mais on a l'habitude maintenant des
paroles et souvent les actes ne suis pas
donc les policiers de toute la france
maintienne la pression sur le pouvoir
exécutif
car la vexation qu'ils ont ressentie
lors de la conférence de presse de lundi
dernier par leur ministre de tutelle
c'était une première dans la défiance
exprimée devant des médias de grande
audience à l'égard des policiers
donc il faudra plus que deux secondes
d'allocutions d'emmanuel macro pour
calmer cette colère policière qui est
sourde
alors jean bien colombien ce avant de
vous faire réagir je voudrais qu'on
revienne justement sur ces propos du
président de la république pour
justement soutenir les forces de l'ordre
écoutez nous ne bâtirons pas davantage
notre avenir dans le désordre sans ordre
républicain
il n'y a ni sécurité ni liberté cet
ordre ce sont les policiers et les
gendarmes sur notre sol qui l'assurent
ils sont exposés à des risques
quotidiens en notre nom
c'est pourquoi ils méritent le soutien
de la puissance publique et la
reconnaissance de la nation alors
jean-pierre à colombiès est ce que vous
partagez la vie de françois bersani pas
suffisant et c'est surtout décalé on a
on a droit depuis mais pas simplement
depuis la semaine dernière depuis des
mois et j'ai presque envie de dire
depuis des années à des discours
contradictoires de beaucoup trop de
politiciens qui font un pas en avant
deux pas en arrière soutiennent des
avoués et c'est de ça que des policiers
ont ces deux stars que les policiers
remontent assez
les mots c'est bien gentil le soutien la
république oui bah il existe la grande
majorité de la citoyenneté soutient sa
police et reconnaît la place de la
police dans sa société mais ce qui n'est
plus entendable c'est cette discordance
entre des membres du gouvernement qu'il
est et non des moindres puisqu'on parle
du ministre de l'intérieur quand même et
les mots du président sont intéressants
mais à titre personnel me paraissent
complètement insuffisant il faut des
actes maintenant les policiers de
terrain ne se satisferont pas de voeux
pieux de parole je dirais générique un
de slogans oui on aime la police on a
besoin de la police mais ça les
policiers le savent qu'on a besoin de la
police parce que ils sont confrontés
quotidiennement à des problématiques de
quartier de problématiques de secteurs
dans des vide de plus en plus difficile
où il est de plus en plus difficile de
faire régner l'ordre et il faudra autre
chose que des voeux pieux autre chose
que de simples une simple reconnaissance
formelle il faudra bien autre chose il
faut tout cela se concrétise dans les
faits c'est à dire en donnant les moyens
nécessaires à la police de retourner
dans les secteurs il ne suffira pas de
parler de reconquête républicaine pour
que ça se passe comme ça en claquant des
doigts
ça fait plus de vingt ans que la police
a été retiré des quartiers retirer de
certains secteurs difficiles
aujourd'hui elle est confrontée à une
délinquance vous parler de ça c'est de
ça qu'il faut parler c'est d'une des
vacances de plus en plus violente qui
n'a peur de rien qui ne qui prend tous
les risques pour défier l'ordre
républicain alors la vraie question est
de savoir ce que finalement on veut on
veut donner et ce qu'on veut redonner la
place que l'on veut donner à la police
dans la société du futur dans le monde
d'après comme il a été dit on a gâché
des munitions on a gâché beaucoup trop
de munitions et en fait tout ça se fait
sur le dos des flics des policiers de
terrain qu'on en voit régulièrement je
dirais et éteindre des feux par ci par
là mais le problème dans son ensemble
n'est pas pris en compte
il ya un problème de société et à un
problème véritablement de maintien de
l'ordre dans des secteurs entiers et
simplement assuré
paraphraser certaines certes un certain
mode d'emploi en disant que oui l'ordre
républicain est maintenue par la police
mais ça on le sait on n'a pas besoin de
ce rappel ce dont la citoyenneté a
besoin c'est d'une police forte soutenue
et que la chaîne judiciaire répondent à
cette attente parce que c'est pas
simplement la police qui est en ce
moment en cause ou ou du moins qui est
fragilisée c'est tout un système un
système qu'il faut mettre à plat et je
dirais des manifestations de policiers
ne suffiront pas il faut véritablement
que tous les corps de métiers qui sont
dans la cerlangue dans la fonction
publique et réagissent et se mettre
d'accord fassent front commun à la
notion de service public qui est qu'ils
étaient très dégradés ces dernières
années vous faites quand vous entendez
pardonner on regarde où évidemment vous
redonner la parole jean pierre colombier
se fait quand vous entendez voilà votre
collègue parler voilà de fait concret
vous partager le même avis quelles
seraient les urgences pour vous a
commencé peut-être
voilà vous auriez attendu un acte fort
du président qui demande tout simplement
la démission de son ministre de
l'intérieur qui ne nous a pas soutenus
par exemple je dirais que le combat
aujourd'hui des policiers c'est le même
combat que pour le personnel soignant
ce sont des professions qui en cas de
crise grave comme lors de la crise qu
vide
eh bien la france compte sur eux le
pouvoir exécutif compte sur eux ce sont
des remparts est essentiel sur deux
aspects un peu différent la santé et la
protection mais au final on reste quand
même sur le domaine de la protection
médicale dans dans l'une et - médicale
dans l'autre mais en dehors de ces
crises
eh bien ce sont deux segments de la
population de la fonction publique qui
sont abandonnés et qu'on estime devoir
laisser un petit peu sur le bord de la
route car en fait que leur conscience
professionnelle leur loyauté
eh bien ils seront toujours là le jour
où on aura besoin d'eux mais pour ces
deux professions qui sont en crise car
les problèmes de fond que rencontrent
ces des professions ne jamais été
traités alors il ya eu quelques avancées
par exemple sur lundi sierre pour ce qui
concerne la police ces dernières années
au prix de manifestations ça c'est sûr
mais sur l'émission sur quel
implantation dans le pays sur justement
quelle forme de police de ton pour le
futur est-ce qu'on veut remettre la
police près de la population on nous
parle aujourd'hui beaucoup de la
fracture qui existerait entre la
population et sa police
mais pour résoudre éventuellement ce
début de fracture ou cette petite
entorse et bien il faut des il faut des
décisions de fond des décisions
stratégiques et pour l'instant on n'a
pas vu de réelle stratégie mise en place
par les ministres de la terre qui se
succèdent justement jean pierre colombet
sur ce lien qui se disent ton entre les
policiers et la population vous vous
l'expliquez comment est ce que le
ministre les différents ministres de
l'intérieur ont leur rôle à jouer
justement dans cette communication entre
les français et leur police
je vous répondrai simplement bonjour je
suis tout à fait d'accord à ce qui vient
d'être dit mais ça concerne pas
simplement ministre de l'intérieur ça
concerne une vraie volonté d'un
gouvernement y est ce qui manque en ce
moment c'est quoi c'est une vision
globale une vision globale de ce que de
la place du service public dans ce pays
la facture entre la police et la
citoyenneté le remonte à une vingtaine
d'années environ lorsqu'on a cassé
purement et simplement la police de
proximité sans s'interroger sur
l'utilité qu'elle pouvait avoir dans les
secteurs et ça sans ressort tous les
niveaux au niveau de la plantation des
policiers dit des policiers de quartier
qui ne sont plus présents qui
aujourd'hui sont vus comme des ennemis à
abattre par une frange et une certaine
frange de la population ces quartiers
parce qu'il faut pas faire d'amalgamé ne
nous y trompons pas la grande majorité
de ces quartiers le voit d'un bon oeil
l'arrivée des policiers
c'est simplement une frange de
délinquance qui redoutent la pénétration
des policiers dans les secteurs qui ne
veulent plus de cette présence est
malheureusement allé souvent visibles
uniquement très ponctuellement par des
lords opération maintien de l'ordre
visuel très souvent politicienne nous
montre ses muscles on dit tiens voilà la
police est là elle est présente regarder
que mon effort comme on est beau sauf
que ça suffit pas sauf que c'est pas de
ça qu'il s'agit
ce dont il s'agit c'est ce qui a été
cassé ya une vingtaine d'années c'est
une présence quotidienne
ce qu'il faut rétablir c'est un
partenariat politique doyenneté qui a
disparu quand la casse et de manière
dogmatique faut bien bien s'en rendre
compte à dogmatique et avec des
paramètres économiques tout simplement
parce que cette police du quotidien et
coûte cher parce qu'il faut mettre des
cadets policiers dans les quartiers et
des policiers qui n'ont pas
nécessairement ou exclusivement une
fonction répressive
parce que le gardien de la paix où le
policier dans sa globalité n'est pas
simplement là pour être répressif ça
doit être un interlocuteur des quartiers
l'interlocuteur de la population de la
citoyenneté et de cela on n'a pas voulu
il ya une vingtaine d'années on a
décrété que policiers devaient avoir un
visage essentiellement répressif et
c'est une erreur grave et on en paie
aujourd'hui les conséquences
il faut revenir là dessus il faut avoir
ce que je me répète mais quand dans une
vision globale de ce qu'on veut du
service public dans ce pays et pour
revenir sur les soignants
je suis tout à fait d'accord on il doit
y avoir une solidarité vraiment très
forte entre aujourd'hui les personnels
policiers et les personnels soignants
parce qu'on a la même la même vision la
même fonction c'est à dire de rendre
service de soulager la difficulté
difficulté et la douleur de certains on
est là pour les protéger
on n'est pas là simplement pour montrer
qu'on est les plus forts et qu'on est
capable de tout cas c'est enfin là il ya
un vrai débat qui est totalement tronqué
on fait payer aujourd'hui à la police et
à ses agents hommes et femmes qui sont
sur le terrain les errements et des
incohérences du politique de ce pays
et ça vraiment faut avoir le courage de
le dire on est gouverné depuis des
années maintenant par des gens qui
voient la police uniquement comme un
outil électoral
on se targue de chiffres de bons
chiffres plus ou moins valables
d'ailleurs plus ou moins manipulés plus
ou moins tronquée
il faut sortir de cette dynamique est
pour ça qu il faut une vision il faut
des hommes d'état qui est véritablement
la capacité de poser des problèmes à
plat de voir ce qu'il n'y a pas que ce
soit en interne dans la police puisque
deux choses ne vont pas c'est évident et
un corporatisme dont on souffre et je
pense pas que mon collègue syndicalisme
disent au contraire on souffre d'un
corporatisme et de difficultés
relationnelles en interne qui explique
considérablement la soixantaine de
suicides qu'on a eu l'année dernière
qu'on a un petit peu oublié on a mis ça
sous le tapis et c'est bien dommage
parce que les problèmes qui étaient
dénoncés il ya des mois sont toujours
présents ils sont toujours là et
aujourd'hui le coup qui leur a été donné
le coup qui était donnée aux policiers
par des prises de paroles mais
complètement décalé on le paie au
centuple et une relaxe
c'est normal qu'ils ne l'acceptent pas
on entend parler de nouvelles de
nouvelles notions juridiques ils sortent
du chapeau comme la notion de soupçons
avérés comme le fashion c'est
incompréhensible du point de vue de la
jante terrain incompréhensible et
surtout inacceptable
françois bersani aujourd'hui on a vu
donc à nouveau un des policiers mettent
leurs menottes à terre c'est très
symbolique selon vous jusqu'où ira cette
mobilisation de la police
et bien aujourd'hui 200 policiers
étaient rassemblés à à versailles et
quand on a sondé la première la première
revendication la première doléance delà
de la base puisque ce mouvement depuis
jeudi est vraiment issu des rangs du
terrain les organisations syndicales
pour une fois je dirais nos quasiment
pas eu à stimuler ou à organiser quoi
que ce soit elien la revendication
première aujourd'hui et les nuits qui
ont précédé et les jours qui précèdent
c'est clairement la démission du
ministre de l'intérieur pour la majeure
partie des policiers que je représente
aujourd'hui christophe castaner ne peut
plus être le premier flic de france
les déclarations à l'emporte-pièce de
lundi dernier
viennent s'ajouter à sa politique
concernant le non port du masque
puisqu'il l'a interdit alors haussé bien
c'était sur les consignes venant du
pouvoir exécutif qu'il était supérieur
mais il a interdit à ses propres hommes
ses propres policiers de porter le port
dit de porter le masque pendant tout
l'épisode du coc vide et ça vient après
d'autres prises de position hostiles aux
forces de l'ordre
donc aujourd'hui c'est vrai que il est
discrédité à à ce poste et il devrait
d'ailleurs tiré lui même en tant
qu'homme politique des contraintes tirer
des leçons
en tout cas de cette mobilisation forte
et qui en plus est une mobilisation un
peu exceptionnelle puisqu'elle
transcende
elle transcende les corps de la police
nationale aujourd'hui comme les autres
nuit il y avait sur le terrain des
commissaires de police
il y avait des officiers de police on a
pu en voir hier soir place de varsovie
ou autour de l'arc de triomphe
et il y aussi donc le corps des gardiens
et gradés mais au nez
od passe voilà on ne dépasse les
rivalités éventuelle de corps que l'on
peut voir d'habitude au sein de la
police nationale
merci à tous les deux j'en perds
colombiès et françois bersani d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france et
autres colère on en a parlé avec vous
messieurs celle du personnel soignant
organisations syndicales politiques
associations et gilet jaune prépare un
coup de force soit demain un peu partout
en france plusieurs manifestations
prévues pour crier le mélèze du monde
hospitalier
malgré la neige du ségur de la santé des
soignants craignent de ne pas être
suffisamment entendu la dgep dera sach
le temps des applaudissements est révolu
plus que de belles paroles et des gestes
symboliques le personnel soignant
réclament plus de moyens c'est le cas
déjà depuis 14 mois de grèves de
manifestations et une crise sanitaire
qui a fait près de trente mille morts en
france les politiques d'austérité menées
par les différents gouvernements
successifs avant la crise sanitaire et
les non prise en compte de ce
gouvernement en matière de santé et
d'action sociale ont généré des carences
en matière de prise en charge qui se
sont accentuées pendant la pandémie due
qu'aux vite 19 un retour à la normale
est inenvisageable pour les usagers ce
n'est plus le temps d'applaudir les
soignants mais de soutenir nos
revendications qui sont aussi les vôtres
nous le répétons les professionnels ne
se contenteront plus de belles promesses
et de demi mesure une colère qui doit
être de nouveau exprimé ce mardi aux
quatre coins de la france
une mobilisation qui s'annonce massive
et qui intervient en plein milieu du
ségur de la santé lancée par l'exécutif
le 25 mai est censé aboutir d'ici à mi
juillet dans son allocution du 14 juin
emmanuel macron a tenté de rassurer le
président de la république a promis de
mieux faire grâce à l'engagement
exceptionnel de nos soignants et de
toutes les équipes
l'ensemble des malades qui en avait
besoin ont pu être prises en charge à
l'hôpital
ou dans la médecine de ville cette
reconstruction doit aussi être social et
solidaire une relance par la santé comme
nous avons commencé à le faire avec la
négociation du ségur qui non seulement
revalorisera les personnels soignants
mais permettra de transformer l'hôpital
comme la médecine de ville par des
investissements nouveaux et une
organisation plus efficace et préventive
une relance solidaire qui permettra de
mieux protéger nos aînés une grande
réforme de l'hôpital qui est loin de
satisfaire les syndicats
plusieurs d'entre eux dénoncent une
imposture
contrairement à ce que dit le
gouvernement non l'hôpital n'a pas su
faire face des personnes âgées atteintes
du coc vite 19 n'ont pas pu être prises
en charge à cause du manque de lits en
réanimation
ce n'est pas ce qu'on veut le ségur de
la santé ne doit pas est une imposture
une pure opération de communication une
montagne qui n'accoucherait que d'une
souris
le jour d'après ne sera pas le retour au
jour d'avant début de réponse du
gouvernement avec la prime qu'ovide de
1000 à 1500 euros
elle est destinée au personnel ayant
exercé entre le 1er et le 30 avril
objectif de cette prime défiscaliser
d'après le ministère de la santé
valoriser l'engagement sans faille des
personnels hospitaliers et des ehpad
pendant cette crise sanitaire
mais pour le personnel soignant auquel
le gouvernement a prévu de rendre
hommage le 14 juillet lors de la fête
nationale c'est loin d'être suffisant
première revendication peut être la plus
importante l'augmentation des salaires
les syndicats réclament en effet 300
euros de plus par mois pour s'aligner
sur la moyenne européenne
autre revendication des créations de
postes et l'annulation des suppressions
de lits 17500 religion en effet disparu
au cours des six dernières années et
pour en parler nous sommes avec thierry
amouroux infirmiers porte parole du
syndicat national des professionnels
infirmiers
et bonsoir thierry amouroux merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france donc
demain c'est le grand jour un grand
mobilisation nationale avec évidemment
les gestes barrières selon vous est ce
que c'est un appel qui va être suivi
alors oui il ya un millier de
rassemblement qui sont organisées dans
toute la france autour des hôpitaux ou
des ehpad dans les différentes villes et
l'idée c'est justement que l'ensemble de
la population soit au tour d'aidés
soignants pour défendre leur hôpital et
protéger leur vie avec un service de
santé à leur service et est donc ainsi
les la population va faire pression sur
les maires qui préside l'instance de
l'hôpital et sur les parlementaires dans
leur circonscription
parce que ce sont les parlementaires
qu'ils votent le budget de l'hôpital
chaque année et chaque année une vote un
budget en baisse depuis dix ans c'était
important pour vous de manifester en
marge du ségur de la santé parce que vu
de l'extérieur quand on connaît pas bien
le dossier on se dit voilà il ya des
négociations quand même qu'ils sont en
cours très activement pour les soignants
et pourtant la pression est maintenue
plus que jamais oui parce que clairement
eu le ségur de la santé ne se passe pas
grand chose
c'est une suite de deux monologues il
n'y a pas de concertation et encore
moins de négociations vous parliez des
salaires mais rien n'est prévu en termes
concrets ni la somme finale ni combien
de temps et il va falloir d'année pour
atteindre cette somme finale rien n'est
prévu du tout sur les réouvertures de
deux lits et les créations de postes
rien n'est prévu non plus donc c'est
pour ça qu'on fait vraiment appel à la
population pour
être là la pression si vous voulez c'est
un bras de fer entre les premiers de
cordée et les premiers de corvée parce
que on a vraiment l'impression d'être
corvéables à merci et que au moment de
prendre vraiment lu problème à bras le
corps
il n'ya pas visiblement les moyens de le
faire vous voyez il ya des milliards qui
ont été débloqués pour l'aéronautique
pour l'automobile et pour l'hôpital où
il attendait on va réfléchir on va se
donner deux mois pour essayer de trouver
une solution
il ya eu 50 rapports qui ont été faits
sur les dix dernières années pour
améliorer la situation de l'hôpital
elle n'a fait que se dégrader et encore
aujourd'hui il ya des problèmes de
fermeture de lits à tour à saint-etienne
au vinatier près près de lyon à besançon
voilà les au quotidien nous hospitalier
nous sommes obligés de nous battre pour
conserver un nombre de lits suffisant
donc voilà un peu le bras de fer dans
lequel on a besoin trop naïve mais est
ce que le gouvernement a le choix
cette crise a révélé au monde entier les
lacunes de l'hôpital public a eu ce
soutien massif de la population
l'hommage du 14-juillet l'enfer on sait
qu'on est dans les symboles mais mais
tout de même ils vont être obligés de
faire des gestes vous n'êtes même pas un
peu confiants écoutez nous avons le
recul du plan hôpital de novembre
dernier annoncée par le premier ministre
qui nous disait qu'il allait consacrer
des milliards à l'hôpital et un mois
après ils ont bu voter le budget de
financement la sécurité sociale pour
l'année 2020 et ben l'argent n'y était
pas en fait
le vote de l'ondam se traduisait par une
baisse de 500 millions d'euros sur le
budget de l'hôpital pour 2020 alors
depuis il faut vite donc on a engagé
davantage de de dépenses mais ça
n'empêche qu'on est inquiet si autant de
directeurs d'hôpitaux qui sur le terrain
se permettent de fermer des lits
supprimer des postes
c'est qu'il ya des consignes orales
alors question annexe à cette
manifestation à ce que finalement elle
est autorisée
parce que c'était assez flou emmanuel
macron a parlé des rassemblements hier
qui ne semble pas les bienvenus en
pleine épidémie mais à la fin de cette
épidémie est en tout cas est-ce que tout
simplement votre rassemblement m
manifestation est elle autorisée par les
autorités
vous avez eu une réponse claire du
conseil d'état qui a rappelé au
gouvernement que le droit en france
s'applique et la règle constitutionnelle
du droit de manifester ça pique voilà
donc ya le rassemblement de paris qui
ira du ministère à l'assemblée nationale
nous avons demandé à être reçu mais le
plus important c'est vraiment où ses
rassemblements dans autour d'un millier
d'hôpitaux une belle mobilisation
populaire de la france qu'on aime
merci en tout cas thierry amouroux et
nous suivons évidemment sur rt france
cette mobilisation demain du personnel
soignant merci à vous restez avec nous
dans quelques instants nous parlerons de
la chine plus de 100 nouveaux cas de
kobe 19 ont été recensés à pékin depuis
que la maladie a fait sa réapparition
dans la ville chinoise c'est ce qu'a
annoncé aujourd'hui l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
et puis direction le liban beyrouth qui
durcit le ton après plusieurs jours de
manifestations dans le pays et met en
garde contre les actes de vandalisme
non
[Musique]
ça fait maintenant plusieurs je dirais
tu décennies presque que la france ou
financent sa recherche et son
enseignement supérieur à quoi est-ce que
vous attribuez ce manque de moyens c'est
un un problème politique au sens où ça
serait pas devant le projet politique
la recherche n'a pas la place qu'elles
devraient avoir parce que la recherche
est un élément central dans la prise en
compte et très très grande et fine fait
qu'elle nous sommes et en particulier le
défi que ses conséquences et maman les
pandémies
là c'est la première mais qui va y en
avoir d'autres
il faut qu'ils aient une prise de
conscience collective vraiment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire
mondiale quel rôle doit selon vont jouer
à levin et quel rôle joue-t-elle dans
les faits les villes tout comme les
états ils étaient pas préparés
mais les villes elles se sont connectés
tout de suite entre elles pour voir
comment elles pouvaient coopérer
il ya eu l'envoi des beaucoup de des
masques de matériels médicaux d'une
commune à l'autre selon vous à quoi
pourront ressembler les îles comment
est-ce qu'elles vont se transformer
après la pandémie la crise maintenant à
fait bien comprendre qu'on peut pas
s'oublier des banlieues on peut pas
oublier les quartiers pauvres parce que
véritablement ils font partie de la vie
donc les grandes villes quand il se
connecte n est pas seulement d'elle-même
elle parle aussi de comment créer cette
cercle vertueux avec les villes des
alentours
[Musique]
l'histoire est plus compliquée que
certains veulent nous le faire croire
vouloir à la réécrire pour faire oublier
les échecs ne permet pas de comprendre
ce qui s'est vraiment passé
c'est ainsi que dans certains manuels de
cours d'histoire de nos enfants on veut
faire oublier napoléon bonaparte grand
organisateur de l'état moderne au profit
de robespierre
le père de la terreur j'ai écouté le
président train pratiquer le déni en
oubliant carrément l'allier qui a eu le
triste privilège d'avoir le plus grand
nombre de morts dans la deuxième garde
mais si j'ai bien compris ils sont morts
pour rien puisque au nom d'une idéologie
on nie leur existence en oubliant une
partie de la game
[Musique]
21h30 merci nous rejoindre en direct sur
rt france
la chine est elle à l'aube d'une
deuxième vague de l'épidémie coronavirus
est la question que se posent pékin
après l'apparition ce week-end 200
nouveaux cas un important marché
alimentaire est pointé du doigt il n a
fait radiant alors que le coe vide 19
semblait presque éradiquée sur le sol
chinois
le pays reste sous la menace d'une
deuxième vague
au total ce week-end 75 nouveaux cas ont
été dénombrés
rien qu'à pékin mis en cause le marché
de gros de xyntha dit l'un des plus
importants de la région dans le sud de
la capitale
très surveillé selon les autorités ce
marché qui vend en poissons viandes et
légumes serait le foyer de la vague de
contamination qui préoccupe les
autorités
les médias officiels ont notamment
rapporté que le virus avait été détecté
sur des planches servant à découper du
saumon emporté une information
inquiétante quand on sait que le marché
de green fadi fourni plus de 80 % des
restaurants de pékin mais l'information
ne semble pas inquiéter les pékinois qui
reste plutôt serein je pense que la
probabilité qu'il y ait une épidémie
majeure est faible
des milliers de personnes tout au plus
c'est mon avis personnel parce qu'il est
facile de vous retrouver grâce aux
données du gouvernement
pékin dispose de suffisamment de
ressources médicales je ne pense pas que
ce soit au site et kahone
il ya eu de la panique lors de la
première vague mais pour la deuxième
vague
il n'y a pas lieu de s'inquiéter nous
avons les données
le gouvernement contrôle les choses
strictement la population est vigilante
il ne devrait pas y avoir de problème il
n'y a pas de raison de paniquer je pense
qu'ici ça va après tout c'est très loin
tous ces gens vont être testés alors ça
va en plus le flux de personnes est
limitée ici donc je ne suis pas très
inquiète
cette découverte a donc entraîné le
confinement de vente et une zone
résidentielle
entre dimanche et lundi face à cette
agitation
la ville a également annoncé pour cette
semaine une campagne massive de
dépistage à laquelle ont déjà été soumis
2000 employés du marché quant aux
autorités sanitaires
elles ont ordonné une campagne
d'inspection dans toute la ville et les
responsables de pékin ne compte pas
s'arrêter là
ils se disent prêts à retracer le
parcours d'environ 200000 personnes qui
auraient visité le marché
nous avons organisé des activités de
porte-à-porte cela signifie que nous
allons rendre visite aux gens qui sont
allés au marché les appeler au téléphone
ou bien les contacter par messagerie
s'ils sont testés positifs ils seront
placés en quarantaine
à noter par ailleurs que la chine et
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
travaille toujours en étroite
collaboration
malgré les nombreuses critiques
internationales sur la gestion de la
crise ducobu de 19 ans et pour en parler
nous sommes avec emmanuel sarrazin un
médecin généraliste cofondateur du
collectif médecin ses 19 ans
bonsoir emmanuel sarrazin merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
vous êtes à l'origine on l'appelle de la
plainte déposée par six ans praticien
l'encontre du premier ministre et de
l'ex ministre de la santé pour mensonge
d'état
vous vous disais vous même lanceur d
alerte parce que aujourd'hui vous lancer
l' alerte à propos de la résurgence de
cas à pékin
bonsoir non je pense que pékin allait
mesurer on le voit ici
ce qu'il faut c'est à dire qu'ils vont
tester le plus de personnes possible et
ils ont mis en quarantaine déjà la zone
incriminée
c'est un cluster comme on peut et on en
aura sans doute en france aussi mais là
bas on voit que les moyens ont été mis
c'est-à-dire tester les gens et être
confiné de façon raisonnable la zone
incriminée
donc vous êtes confiant quand on parle
de crainte d'une deuxième vague dans
déjà ici ou là nous dire voilà ça se
passe en chine ça va se passer de la
même manière ça va venir en europe après
vous tenez à rassurer ces personnes
créatives
oui moi je pense que avant de parler de
deuxième vague on peut parler d'un gros
cluster on aura forcément en europe
aussi et en france aussi je pense comme
on l'a déjà eu dans les jours précédents
des clusters important le seul problème
chez nous c'est le problème de manque de
test et ce manque de
de rigueur dans le confinement cibler
des gens testé positivement quoi ce
qu'on aurait dû faire déjà dès le début
ça va pas aujourd'hui clairement
emmanuel sarrazin les gens susceptibles
d'être contaminés sont testés mais si
j'ose dire là près le service après
vente entre guillemets pardonnez moi
cette expression ne se fait pas bien
passé rigoureusement alors je dis
d'abord il teste pas encore de façon
assez massive
actuellement on n'est pas au nombre de
tests voluer annoncées par le
gouvernement comme depuis le début c'est
comme des masques on nous avait promis
des tests nombreux est en finale on se
on s'aperçoit qu'on a du mal à tester
les gens et deuxièmement oui les mesures
de confinement pour l'instant ont été de
manière générale mais pas de manière
ciblée il sent que on va y venir mais on
attend de voir
on va y venir c'est à dire c'est à dire
que quand les gens sont testés
positivement il faudrait un les isolés
soit chez eux soit dans des structures
adaptées type des hôtels des centres de
vacances testé après selon des cercles
les proches et ainsi de suite et isolé
tout ce monde là avant résulte en
attendant le résultat des tests et ne
donnait l'autorisation de sortie de
travail d'aller à l'école qu'après quoi
est pour l'instant en tout cas nous à
notre niveau on n'a pas cette mise en
place et pourtant olivier ferrand disait
il ya quelques jours voilà on a sept
cent mille tests mais on ne va pas
forcément tous les utiliser parce que on
en a pas forcément le besoin et qui
d'amy est en train de de s'éloigner ça
veut dire selon vous qu on est un petit
peu trop
voilà trop laxiste on n'est pas assez
prenants pourtant le gouvernement
entende d'appeler clairement
régulièrement la prudence oui là il
appelle à la prudence mais depuis le
départ on a quand même un vent de
panique et des mesures qui sont
contradictoires
au départ il fallait pas de masque un
jour appelle au départ il allait tester
que les malades non il faut pas testé
que les malades il faut tester aussi
tout il aurait fallu tester aussi le
plus de personnes possible afin d'éviter
justement que les gens tombent malades
donc on est un petit peu dans une
incohérence et un manque d'organisation
depuis le début sous l'effet de la
panique je pense j'ose l'espérer
en tout cas on n'était pas prêts on ne
l'est toujours pas puisque on est
toujours en pénurie de masques on a
toujours autant de mal ce toit se
trouvaient des masques
les patients ont de nombreux patients
aussi et quant aux tests
bah c'est pas 700 milles qui sont faits
comme comme il est dit alors on revient
au début à notre interview on va la
refermer comme ça qu'est ce que c'était
l'objet de votre invitation
ce entre guillemets vous vous la paix
cluster à pékin à nouveau c'est un
marché alimentaire qui est suspecté pour
vous est ce qu'on en fait assez
justement on se dit voilà pour la
deuxième fois c'est un marché
alimentaire qui est suspecté est ce que
les autorités chinois sont invités
voilà on revoir peut-être leur méthode
en fils je ne sais pas quelles sont
leurs méthodes je les connais pas en
tout cas c'est sûr qu'il faut faire
attention on sait que le virus a une
durée de vie sur des matériaux inertes
qui peuvent aller de sur plusieurs jours
donc effectivement il ya des mesures
d'hygiène à respecter est ce qu'ils sont
respectés en chine je ne sais pas en
tout cas je sais qu'en france dans sur
les marchés à des mesures de d'hygiène
qui sont qui sont mises en place depuis
le confinement et il faut continuer à
les respecter puisque la première chose
en finale sur les mesures barrières qui
nous protège tous et protège de la
propagation du virus quoi ces 19 avoir
été avec nous
direct sur arte france merci à vous
merci à vous beyrouth durci autant
aujourd'hui après plusieurs jours de
manifestations dans le pays les
autorités promettent ainsi des
arrestations alors que le liban est au
bord de l'effondrement économique la
semaine dernière rassemblement des
blocages de routes avaient secoué le
pays notamment à beyrouth et tripoli un
regain de tension due à la forte
dépréciation de la livre libanaise
aujourd'hui le gouvernement met en garde
contre les actes de vandalisme selon
président michel aoun des opérations
préventives seront organisées dans les
prochains jours ce qu'a également
expliqué le général marot de al asmar
secrétaire général du conseil supérieur
de défense
ces événements ont provoqué un
mécontentement général qui exigent que
des mesures strictes soient prises pour
empêcher qu'ils ne se reproduisent
en plus d'une vague d'arrestations
englobant ceux qui ont planifié et
exécuté de tels actes ne s'agit pas de
manifestation contre la faim où la
situation économique est un sabotage
organisé ce qui incite ceux qui les paie
et ceux qui les dirigent de l'intérieur
et de l'extérieur doivent être arrêtés
et pour en parler nous sommes nous avec
david rivaux les roses chercheur
spécialiste du moyen-orient associé à
l'institut de relations internationales
et stratégiques rédacteur en chef
également de la revue orient stratégique
bonsoir david rigoulet roze merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france et
autorités libanaises qui durcissent donc
le temps promettant des arrestations
pour les actes de vandalisme
quels messages ont voulu faire passer
les autorités selon vont oui une
inquiétude perceptible de la part des
autorités qui ont l'impression que la
situation est susceptible de l'art
échappé c'est vrai que ces derniers
jours les diverses manifestations que
soient mes routes ou à tripoli ont
montré qu'il y avait 1
une modification par rapport à aux
manifestations initiale des premières
semaines en octobre
on n'est plus du tout dans l'esprit
salmiya ses dires des manifestations
pacifiques il ya une violence qui est en
train de monter alors évidemment il ya
le gall l'affichage est un discours
complotistes on est en orient ce c'est
très souvent il ya effectivement l'idée
qu'ils auraient une main invisible qui
serait derrière les diverses
manifestations violentes
il ya des tensions incontestable au
niveau politique parce que derrière la
nomination du premier ministre hassan
diable il ya eu des difficultés 1 pour
la mise en place du gouvernement à
partir de janvier dernier
mais on sort de là de la période aussi
de parce qu on est dans la période post
copie d'un et les problèmes qu'ils
étaient prêts existants prennent un tour
absolument dramatique c'est à dire avec
des vagues de licenciements massifs
il ya un effondrement du pip qui est
prévu à plus de 12% 45% la population
est aujourd'hui passé sous le seuil de
la pauvreté et donc il ya il ya une
dimension clairement émeutes de la faim
qui commencent à surgir et qui est
effectivement problématique pour les
autorités politiques
vous décrivez évidemment cette situation
politique dramatique au liban dont on
parle depuis longtemps effectivement
avant même le convive 19 comment le pays
peut-il désormais son sens relevé on
parle beaucoup de l'intervention du fmi
est ce que c'est une piste que les
libanais accueille avec bienveillance le
preuve c'est que le liban n'a pas tu n
as pas de marge de manoeuvre si dire que
début mars dernier le premier ministre a
dit qu'il ne pouvait pas assurer le
remboursement d'une partie de la dette
de l'ordre de 1 milliard et demi en
prendront donc c'était une manière de
signifier un défaut sur la dette
libanaise avec en arrière-plan
évidemment ce qui se profile si la
dévaluation de la monnaie et la
d'émanations elle est déjà dans les
faits puisque au marché noir
effectivement elle est passée à 1 $ pour
5000 livres
alors même si les autorités ont injecté
des dollars pour faire baisser
effectivement le
le légume pour limiter la baisse du
pouvoir d'achat si ce n'est que partie
remise et donc la situation
effectivement est dramatique et il ya
une personnalité qui est visé c'est le
le celle de mai le directeur de la
banque centrale riad salamé
effectivement qui est accusé d'avoir une
certaine manière valider un système un
modèle économique qui a conduit
aujourd'hui à la situation qu'on connaît
au liban aujourd'hui comment peut-on se
sortir de ça on sait que des
manifestants demandent
voilà un changement de système un
changement de personne au gouvernement
la fin de la corruption est ce que les
autorités ont pris quand même les
mesures de ces appels de colère très
persistant et qui datent pas d'hier
oui c'est le premier ministre d'ailleurs
a dit qu' il entamé la guerre contre la
corruption mais que ça allait très
difficile parce qu'il ya une résistance
de ceux qui sont partie prenante de ce
système
et la vérité c'est que tout le liban et
les fonds et un repose sur en grande
partie sur un système de népotisme et de
corruption et donc que c'est extrêmement
difficile de changer de paradigme
surtout dans une situation aussi
dramatique que celle d'aujourd'hui et il
y avait évidemment des aides qui avait
été proposé avec la conférence cèdre en
avril 2018 à paris mais c'était son site
est conditionnée par un certain nombre
de réformes structurelles qui n'ont
jamais été menés depuis
et là on sait la quadrature du cercle
effectivement pour le gouvernement
actuel qui n'a plus du tout une marge de
manoeuvre et qui se retrouve confronté à
une situation qui n'a plus rien à voir
une certaine manière avec avec une
dimension strictement politique comme ça
a pu l'être à partir du 17 octobre
là on est clairement dans une logique
délétère avec des violences qui sont
susceptibles de dégénérer et où tout le
monde est profondément inquiet parce que
grande partie de la population n'a tout
simplement plus les moyens de subvenir à
ses besoins
la question peut paraître naïve mais
elle est important parce que c'est vrai
qu'on a parfois du mal à comprendre
cette situation d'un pays aussi riche à
tous les niveaux riche en ressources
riches en diversité
comment expliquer ce gâchis aujourd'hui
alors riche en diversité c'est
incontestable notamment confessionnelles
d'ailleurs s'explique une grande partie
du système qui a été mis en place
de répartition d'expression politique
confessionnel pour le reste c'est plus
sujettes à caution parce que le liban ne
produit rien et c'est tout problème il a
fondé sa prospérité un peu fictif sur un
système de ponzi on va dire c'est à dire
qu'il reposait sur des taux d'intérêt de
la banque centrale justement à deux
chiffres qui étaient très spéculatif et
qui faisait rentrer artificiellement de
l'argent mais à partir du moment où il
ya une défiance par rapport à ces
ascètes donné effectivement financière
et bancaire
le liban se retrouve finalement exemple
et n'est plus aux moyens de payer tout
simplement les importations qui sont de
l'ordre de 90% du pays et donc là là on
se retrouve dans la situation qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui rappeler question
dernière question quelles sont les
réactions des pays voisins qu'elle
peut-être leur marge de manoeuvre est
leur rôle
il ya une grande inquiétude est
d'ailleurs on peut pas dissocier la
situation libanaise deux associations
syriennes parce que la crise qui
aujourd'hui secoue la syrie est en
partie lié d'ailleurs à ceux à ce défaut
sur le système bancaire libanais puisque
les deux avaient partie liée pendant
très longtemps auriez loi mais régime de
sanctions américaines qui la loi césar
qui rentre en vigueur justement contre
la syrie aujourd'hui et qui va peser
encore plus et pas indirectement qui
aurait un impact aussi sur l'évolution
de la situation financière et monétaire
libanaise
merci david rigoler rosa d'avoir été
avec mon direct sur rt france pour
évoquer donc cette situation ol liban
au venezuela à présent l'opposition se
retire des législatives elle estime que
l'organe chargé de superviser les
élections qui devaient se tenir fin 2020
et trop acquise à nicolas maduro
mais deux présidents élus persistent et
signent il estime que le processus
électoral est le seul chemin vers la
paix rania berrada une farce c'est par
ce mot que l'opposition vénézuélienne
qualifie les prochaines législatives
onze partis politiques ont fait savoir
dimanche qu'il ne participerait pas à
cette échéance électorale prévue en 2020
les partis démocratiques vénézuélien ne
validerons ni ne reconnaîtront aucune
farce électorale mise en scène par la
dictature dans son propre intérêt et
pour cause le tribunal suprême de
justice
accusé par l'opposition d'appuyer le
pouvoir chaviste a nommé vendredi cinq
nouveaux membres à la tête du conseil
national électoral
la composition de cet organe chargé de
superviser le scrutin est jugée
défavorable par l'opposition sur les
cinq membres du conseil nommés par le
tribunal suprême de justice
trois sont des proches de nicolas smad
oro dans sa présidente
malgré la décision de l'opposition et de
son chef juan goyer d'eau de se retirer
le président-élu appelle de ses voeux
des élections législatives je crois en
la voie électorale et démocratique
nous sommes prêts à entamer un nouveau
processus électoral populaire lorsque le
pouvoir électoral en décidera ainsi
c'est le seul chemin respect des
institutions et coexistence entre tous
les vénézuéliens
nous devrions opté pour la paix en
décembre 2015
l'opposition avait gagné les élections
législatives en remportant 112 des 160
sièges du parlement depuis la
présidentielle de mai 2018
à l'issue de laquelle nicolás maduro a
été réélu à la tête du pays n a eu de
cesse de fustiger une élection qu'elle
juge frauduleuse et pour fernandez
ancien diplomate et consultant en
amérique latine la stratégie de nicolás
maduro consiste à mettre en lumière les
dissensions de l'opposition on a d'une
part une opposition qui dont le leader
est le dirigeant et erwan bérot lui qui
représente les factions les plus
radicales de cette opposition
enfin pour partie peu respectueuse de
certaines traditions démocratiques ou en
tout cas qui ne rejette pas
les solutions violentes pas principe on
a vu l'année dernière on appris auprès
de 1019 un coup d'état dirigé par
lui-même
on a en mai de cette année une tentative
de de l'opération par des mercenaires
d'une organisation silvercorp essaye on
voit donc une opposition qui n'est pas
homogène qui est fissurée et la
stratégie du président maduro qui vise
finalement à mettre en lumière ses
divisions pour pour isoler ces factions
les plus radicales et les moins
démocratiques est une opération qui peut
avoir un succès dans le sens où lui une
parti d'opposition on le voit
aujourd'hui est tenté par un retour aux
urnes et par une participation à ces
élections et c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve à 22 heures pour un point
complet sur l'actualité
[Musique]
tous les secteurs de la culture sont
sont touchés la musique le cinéma le
théâtre elle les musées avec trois mois
de nos activités ou les billetteries
sont à l'arrêt l'impact financier est
énorme
ce sera des matches sous conditions 1
avec port du masque obligatoire
distanciation physique gestion des flux
que ce que nous attendons c'est
effectivement la possibilité de rouvrir
sans ces mesures barrières le plus vite
possible
on retrouvera pas le marché que nous
avons quitté en 2021
il faudra reconstruire le marché cela
prendra plusieurs mois voire plusieurs
années
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on sait combien on reste traumatisée
bien on cherche en soi et autour de
soins quels sont les facteurs qui vont
nous permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement est l'un fontaine de
résilience la catastrophe économique
dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté 14 trop fine il ya un
tournant et on refermait à vivre mais
dans une autre direction c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire de
l'humanité que pour sauver des vies
humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
simple jamais plaint d'une décision à
vraisemblable pour vous ça dépend telles
valeurs on attribuait la mort la vie
humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie on a bien
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un débat
moral débats éthiques
[Musique]
cela fait maintenant plusieurs je dirais
décennies presque que la france ou
financent sa recherche et son
enseignement supérieur à quoi est-ce que
vous attribuez ce manque de moyens c'est
un un problème politique au sens où ça
serait pas devant le projet politique
la recherche n'a pas la place qu'elles
devraient avoir parce que la recherche
est un élément central dans la prise en
compte et très très grands défis face
auxquels nous sommes aimés en
particulier le défi que ses conséquences
et notamment une panne technique
là c'est la première mais qui finit en
avoir d'eau il faut qu'ils aient pris de
conscience collective
vraiment
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
à
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
recevons pauline d'orgeval présidente et
cofondatrice de kohat petit santé le
pratiquent même de notre association
c'est de réduire les inégalités d'accès
à la santé et d'accès aux soins
on se rend compte que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je finisse par
renoncer aux soins vous avez proposé
deux posters en falck ça que ça veut
dire
facile à lire facile à comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
autisme de comprendre ce qui se passe
tout l'enjeu de notre association c'est
quoi construire les fiches avec les
acteurs associatifs institutionnels
voilà tout se met en place pour
accompagner dans la durée
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
alors ce qui si c'est interdit
d'interdire
[Musique]
l'afrique qui compte 1 1 % de cas dans
le monde sait très peu comment vous
l'expliquez nous devons considérer que
les chiffres sont sous-estimés mais ne
sont pas encore au niveau où se trouve
par exemple l'europe ou les états unis
quelle stratégie vous avez déployés dans
le sud kivu pour limiter la propagation
du virus on a proposé à ce qu'est le
confinement puisse être sélectif est
concerné seulement des personnes âgées à
haut risque de complication pour
sensibiliser la population ça l'est
beaucoup plus facilement puisqu'on
venait de sortir d'une d'une épidémie à
ebola qui exige également la
distanciation social lavage des mains
que si on aura affaire à deux épidémies
aussi dangereuse qui est des mollahs et
le coroner
ça pourrait être très très difficile
pour nous
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
à
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
les forces de l'ordre loin d'être
apaisées après les compos d'emmanuel
macron plusieurs centaines de policiers
ont manifesté hier soir sur l'esplanade
du trocadéro à paris
à nouveau déposer leurs menottes à terre
en signe de protestation
un autre rassemblement ils eurent en
milieu de journée devant l'hôpital de
police de versailles
du côté des soignants également la
colère ne retombe pas l'appel de
plusieurs organisations syndicales une
journée nationale de mobilisation des
personnels des hôpitaux étaient des
craintes décrété pour demain malgré le
ségur de la santé lancée par le
gouvernement ils réclament une
revalorisation des salaires ou bien
encore l'arrêt de toutes les fermetures
d'établissements de service et de lille
[Musique]
tous les regards sont à nouveau tournés
vers la chine avec un rebond du virus à
pékin en plus de 100 cas sont confirmés
selon l' oms
et avec ces chiffres c'est la peur d'une
deuxième bac et ressurgit pékin et je
cite en guerre contre le kobe 19 ans ont
fini les quartiers entiers et referme
ses sites culturels et sport
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
alors que les forces de l'ordre sont
accusés de racisme et de violence ces
derniers jours pour le chef de l'état
policiers et gendarmes mérite le soutien
de la puissance publique et la
reconnaissance de la nation
mais ce soutien n'a visiblement pas
convaincu dans les rangs des forces de
l'ordre hier soir des centaines de
policiers se sont rassemblés sur
l'esplanade du trocadéro et un nouveau
rassemblement a eu lieu en milieu de
journée devant l'hôtel de police de
versailles et précision sur place de
notre reporter katia technique les
rapides mots de soutien d' emmanuel
macron lors de son allocution hier soir
n'ont pas rassuré les policiers bien au
contraire il souhaite que le ministre de
l'intérieur christophe castaner
reviennent sur les propos qu'il a tenus
la semaine dernière et certains
souhaitent qu'il quitte le ministère
s'était un peu le sens de cette action
organisée à 13h30 devant l'hôtel de
police de versailles devant lequel je me
trouve une centaine de policiers du
département sont venus déposer au sol
leur brassard et leurs menottes
une manière d'affirmer leur opposition
notamment au gouvernement le mouvement
de contestation au sein de la police
montrent que les actions commencées dès
jeudi et encore hier soir des centaines
de policiers se sont rejoint sur la
place du trocadéro des policiers de
terrain qui ont contesté ce gouvernement
et ce dans un climat où les
manifestations contre le racisme dans la
police ou les violences policières se
multiplient en france et au sujet de la
colère des forces de l'ordre qu'on
propose d'écouter des analyses de jean
pierre colombiès porte parole de l'union
des policiers nationaux indépendants et
de françois bersani de l'unité sgp
police 78
les policiers aujourd'hui ont besoin de
preuves d'amour
il ya eu des déclarations d'amour hier
soir mais on a l'habitude maintenant des
paroles et souvent les actes ne suivent
pas donc les policiers de toute la
france maintienne la pression sur le
pouvoir exécutif
car la vexation qu'ils ont ressentie
lors de la conférence de presse de lundi
dernier par leur ministre de tutelle
c'était une première dans la défiance
exprimée
devant des médias de grande audience à
l'égard des policiers
donc il faudra plus que deux secondes
d'allocutions d' emmanuel macron pour
calmer cette colère policière qui est
sourde les mots du président sont
intéressants mais à titre personnel me
paraît complètement insuffisant il faut
des actes maintenant les policiers de
terrain ne se satisferont pas de voeux
pieux de parole je dirais générique un
de slogans oui on aime la police on a
besoin de l'appui c'est ça les policiers
le savent qu'on a besoin de la police
parce que ils sont confrontés
quotidiennement à des problématiques de
quartier de problématiques de secteurs
dans des villes de plus en plus
difficile où il est de plus en plus
difficile de faire régner l'ordre et il
faudra autre chose que des voeux pieux
autre chose que de simples une simple
reconnaissance formelle il faudra bien
autre chose il faut que tout cela se
concrétise dans les faits c'est à dire
en donnant les moyens nécessaires à la
police de retourner dans les secteurs il
ne suffira pas de parler de reconquête
républicaine pour que ça se passe comme
ça en claquant des doigts et autres
colère celle du personnel soignant
organisations syndicales politiques
associations et gilet jaune prépare un
coup de force demain un peu partout dans
le pays
plusieurs manifestations prévues pour
crier le malaise du monde hospitalier
malgré l' annonce du ségur de la santé
et soignants craignent de ne pas être
suffisamment entendu nadège à dera sach
le temps des applaudissements est révolu
plus que de belles paroles et des gestes
symboliques le personnel soignant
réclament plus de moyens c'est le cas
déjà depuis 14 mois de grèves de
manifestations et une crise sanitaire
qui a fait près de trente mille morts en
france les politiques d'austérité menées
par les différents gouvernements
successifs avant la crise sanitaire et
les non prise en compte de ce
gouvernement en matière de santé et
d'action sociale ont généré des carences
en matière de prise en charge qui se
sont accentuées pendant la pandémie due
qu'aux vite 19 un retour à la normale
est inenvisageable pour les usagers ce
n'est plus le temps d'applaudir les
soignants mais de soutenir nos
revendications qui sont aussi les vôtres
nous le répétons les
fessionnels ne se contenteront plus de
belles promesses et de demi mesure une
colère qui doit être de nouveau exprimé
ce mardi aux quatre coins de la france
une mobilisation qui s'annonce massive
et qui intervient en plein milieu du
ségur de la santé lancée par l'exécutif
le 25 mai est censé aboutir d'ici à mi
juillet dans son allocution du 14 juin
emmanuel macron a tenté de rassurer le
président de la république a promis de
mieux faire grâce à l'engagement
exceptionnel de nos soignants et de
toutes les équipes
l'ensemble des malades qui en avait
besoin ont pu être prises en charge à
l'hôpital ou dans la médecine de ville
cette reconstruction doit aussi être
social et solidaire une relance par la
santé comme nous avons commencé à le
faire avec la négociation du ségur qui
non seulement revalorisera les
personnels soignants mais permettra de
transformer l'hôpital comme la médecine
de ville par des investissements
nouveaux et une organisation plus
efficace et préventive une relance
solidaire qui permettra de mieux
protéger nos aînés une grande réforme de
l'hôpital qui est loin de satisfaire les
syndicats
plusieurs d'entre eux dénoncent une
imposture
contrairement à ce que dit le
gouvernement non l'hôpital n'a pas su
faire face des personnes âgées atteintes
du coc vite 19 n'ont pas pu être prises
en charge à cause du manque de lits en
réanimation
ce n'est pas ce qu'on veut le ségur de
la santé ne doit pas est une imposture
une pure opération de communication une
montagne qui n'accoucherait que d'une
souris
le jour d'après ne sera pas le retour au
jour d'avant début de réponse du
gouvernement avec la prime qu'ovide de
1000 à 1500 euros
elle est destinée au personnel ayant
exercé entre le 1er et le 30 avril
objectif de cette prime défiscaliser
d'après le ministère de la santé
valoriser l'engagement sans faille des
personnels hospitaliers et des ehpad
pendant cette crise sanitaire
mais pour le personnel soignant auquel
le gouvernement a prévu de rendre
hommage le 14 juillet alors de la fête
nationale c'est loin d'être suffisant
première revendication peut-être la plus
importante l'augmentation des salaires
les syndicats réclament en effet 300
euros de plus par mois pour s'aligner
sur la moyenne européenne
autre revendication des créations de
postes et l'annulation des suppressions
de lits 17500 lice y ont en effet
disparu au cours des six dernières
années
à ses dires de la santé qui pour le
moment est loin d'avoir convaincu
thierry amouroux il est infirmier dans
la php porte parole du syndicat national
des professionnels infirmiers le ségur
de la santé il se passe pas grand chose
c'est une suite de deux monologues il
n'y a pas de concertation et encore
moins de négociations vous parliez des
salaires mais rien n'est prévu en termes
concrets ni la somme finale ni combien
de temps et il va falloir d'année pour
atteindre cette somme finale rien mais
prévu du tout sur les réouvertures de
deux lits et les créations de postes
rien n'est prévu non plus donc c'est
pour ça qu'on fait vraiment appel à la
population pour mettre la pression
si vous voulez c'est un un bras de fer
entre les premiers de cordée et les
premiers de corvée et mène nettement a
convaincu moins de la moitié des
téléspectateurs hier seuls 47% l'ont
trouvé convaincant à sa prise de parole
selon cette enquête est là pour bfm tv
une personne sondée sur cinq trouve le
président de la république
pas convaincu du tout élocution des
médias le mag on était très attendue par
les français plus de 23 millions de
téléspectateurs étaient devant leur
poste hier
relancer des négociations dans l'impasse
c'est l'objectif de la réunion qui s'est
déroulée aujourd'hui entre les
dirigeants des 27 états membres et le
premier ministre britannique
c'est la première fois depuis 2006 que
boris johnson prend part personnellement
aux discussions l'union européenne et le
royaume uni sont convenus de donner un
nouvel élan aux négociations post
bréxent il dans la passe comme je les
dis aux trois présidents mettez un tigre
dans votre moteur car c'est clairement
ce dont a besoin d'angleterre est ce que
nos amis de l'union européenne ont
besoin de comprendre ne pouvons pas
faire participer la cour de justice
européenne dans ce pays
nous ne pouvons pas avoir un système où
nous sommes obligés d'obéir aux
règlements de l'union européenne alors
que nous ne faisons pas partie mais nous
devons donner un coup de boost aux
négociations et je suis très content
cure sur la vente des ryan le président
de la commission charles michel et le
président du conseil est d'avis de
cinsault dit le président du parlement
européen soit d'accord ils ont signé une
bonne déclaration pour nous faire
avancer
nous avons pris note de la décision du
royaume uni de ne pas demander de
prolongation de la période de transition
la période de transition prendra donc
fin le 31 décembre 2020 conformément aux
dispositions de l'accord de retrait
quatre cycles ont été menées à bien et
des textes ont été échangées malgré les
défis posés par la pandémie de covile 19
nous avons néanmoins convenu qu'un
nouvel élan était nécessaire nous avons
soutenu les plans convenu par les
négociateurs en chef en vue
d'intensifier les pourparlers en juillet
et de créer les conditions les plus
propices à la conclusion et à la
ratification d'un accord avant la fin de
cela devrait inclure si possible de
trouver rapidement une compréhension des
principes qui sous-tendent tout accord
nous avons souligné notre intention de
travailler dur pour établir une relation
qui servirait les intérêts des citoyens
de l'union et du royaume uni
nous avons également confirmé notre
engagement en faveur de la mise en
oeuvre intégrale et dans les délais de
l'accord de retrait et journée
décidément chargée pour l'union
européenne sous pression constante des
etats-unis sur les volets diplomatiques
et économiques bruxelles a mis sur la
table ces contentieux avec washington
les ministres des affaires étrangères de
lieux se sont réunis dans la journée par
visioconférence avec mike pompéo le
secrétaire d'état américain
malgré les sujets de discussion houleuse
le chef de la diplomatie européenne a
réaffirmé sa volonté d'une coopération
transatlantique qui vous à vous engager
un dialogue stratégique avec mike pompeo
sur nos relations et sur des questions
clés de politique étrangère à la fois
pour l'union européenne et les etats
unis
comme vous le savez il est inutile de le
souligner mais permettez moi quand même
de le faire le partenariat
transatlantique est l'un des piliers
clefs de l'ordre mondial et aujourd'hui
lors de la réunion les acteurs affirme
l'engagement de l'union européenne à
poursuivre cette coopération
transatlantique étroite
peut-être que nous ne sommes pas
d'accord sur tout mais notre attachement
à la coopération transatlantique est
plus fort que jamais et 16 h 30 à 16
heures écoutez ce sujet l'analyse de
claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales
les spécialistes peuvent négocier un
accord sur le libre échange avec des
indicateurs sur les conditions
équitables de concurrence en matière
fiscale en matière sociale en matière
environnementale puisque c'est ce que
demande l'union européenne le maintien
de droits de pêche que l'union
européenne avait dans les eaux
britanniques est évidemment aussi très
important les britanniques veulent que
ce soit un accord annuel donc remettre
en question chaque année les choses
ce qui n'est pas acceptable pour l'union
européenne il faut donc trouver un
compromis et puis sur la cour de justice
européenne
il serait quand même légitime que
lorsque le désaccord porte sur
l'interprétation de règles de l'union
européenne ce sera la cour de justice
qu'il donne son interprétation et puis
on peut trouver un arrangement pour que
les tribunaux britanniques est aussi
leur mot à dire dans le règlement des
litiges
mais si pour dit johnson a décidé
d'avoir un odile parce que finalement il
a été élu sur un père une plate forme
purement politique sortir le plus vite
possible de l'union européenne et
peut-être dans les conditions plus ou
moins dramatique
si c'est ça c'est mon choix politique
évidemment il n'y aura pas d'accord
parce qu'à ce moment là les ministres
il représentait qu'il négocie avec
monsieur barnier
évidemment ne bougeront pas et l'union
européenne ne bougera pas non plus donc
actuellement je crois que c'est ben
johnson qui a les cartes en main un
accord est possible ça dépend de lui
la chine est elle à l'aube d'une
deuxième vague de l'épidémie de
coronavirus c'est la question que se
posent pékin après l'apparition ce
week-end 200 nouveaux cas un important
marché alimentaire est pointé du doigt
les explications dylan affaires indien
alors que le coe vide 19 semblait
presque éradiquée sur le sol chinois he
le pays reste sous la menace d'une
deuxième vague
au total ce week-end 75 nouveaux cas ont
été dénombrés
rien qu'à pékin mis en cause le marché
de gros de xyntha dit l'un des plus
importants de la région dans le sud de
la capitale
très surveillé selon les autorités ce
marché qui vend en poissons viandes et
légumes serait le foyer de la vague de
contamination qui préoccupe les
autorités
les médias officiels ont notamment
rapporté que le virus avait été détecté
sur des planches servant à découper du
saumon emporté une information
inquiétante quand on sait que le marché
de green fadi fourni plus de 80 % des
restaurants de pékin mais l'information
ne semble pas inquiéter les pékinois qui
reste plutôt serein
je pense que la probabilité qu'il y ait
une épidémie majeure est faible des
milliers de personnes tout au plus c'est
mon avis personnel parce qu'il est
facile de vous retrouver grâce aux
données du gouvernement
pékin dispose de suffisamment de
ressources médicales
je ne pense pas que ce soit au site et
kahone il ya eu de la panique lors de la
première vague mais pour la deuxième
vague
il n'y a pas lieu de s'inquiéter nous
avons les données
le gouvernement contrôle les choses
strictement la population est vigilante
il ne devrait pas y avoir de problème il
n'y a pas de raison de paniquer je pense
qu'ici ça va après tout c'est très loin
tous ces gens vont être testés alors ça
va en plus le flux de personnes est
limitée ici donc je ne suis pas très
inquiète
cette découverte a donc entraîné le
confinement de vente et une zone
résidentielle
entre dimanche et lundi face à cette
agitation
la ville a également annoncé pour cette
semaine une campagne massive de
dépistage à laquelle ont déjà été soumis
2000 employés du marché quant aux
autorités sanitaires
elles ont ordonné une campagne
d'inspection dans toute la ville et les
responsables de pékin ne compte pas
s'arrêter là
ils se disent prêts à retracer le
parcours d'environ 200000 personnes qui
auraient visité le marché
nous avons organisé des activités de
porte-à-porte cela signifie que nous
allons rendre visite aux gens qui sont
allés au marché les appeler au téléphone
ou bien les contacter par messagerie
s'ils sont testés positifs ils seront
placés en quarantaine
à noter par ailleurs que la chine et
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
travaille toujours en étroite
collaboration
malgré les nombreuses critiques
internationales sur la gestion de la
crise ducobu de 19 ans et est cotée à ce
sujet l'analyse d'emmanuel sarrazin un
médecin généraliste cofondateur du
collectif 19 avant de parler deuxième
wagon pour parler d'un gros cluster on
aura forcément
en europe aussi et en france aussi je
pense comme on l'a déjà eu dans les
jours précédents des clusters important
le seul problème chez nous c'est le
problème de manque de test et ce manque
de rigueur dans le confinement cibler
des gens testé positivement quoi au
départ il allait tester que les malades
non il faut pas testé que les malades il
faut tester aussi tout il aurait fallu
tester aussi le plus de personnes
possible afin d'éviter justement que les
gens tombent malades
en tout cas on n'était pas prêts on ne
l'est toujours pas puisque on est
toujours en pénurie de masques on a
toujours autant de mal ce toit se
trouvaient des masques les patients ont
de nombreux patients si mais quand aux
tests
bah c'est pas 700 milles qui sont faits
comme comme il est d'ici beyrouth durci
le ton aujourd'hui après plusieurs jours
de manifestations dans le pays les
autorités promettent ainsi des
arrestations
alors que le liban est au bord de
l'effondrement économique est la semaine
dernière assemblement et blocages de
routes avaient secoué le liban notamment
à beyrouth et tripoli
un regain de tension due à la forte
dépréciation de la livre libanaise
aujourd'hui le gouvernement a mis en
garde contre des actes de vandalisme
selon le président michel aoun des
opérations préventives seront organisées
dans les prochains jours ce qu'a
également expliqué le secrétaire général
du conseil supérieur de défense
ces événements ont provoqué un
mécontentement général qui exigent que
des mesures strictes soient prises pour
empêcher qu'ils ne se reproduisent
en plus d'une vague d'arrestations
englobant ceux qui ont planifié et
exécuté de tels actes ne s'agit pas de
manifestation contre la faim où la
situation économique est un sabotage
organisé ce qui incite ceux qui les paie
et ceux qui les dirigent de l'intérieur
et de l'extérieur doivent être arrêtés
chercheur spécialiste du moyen-orient
socialiste rédacteur en chef de la revue
orient stratégique des manifestations ne
sont plus pacifiste mais violente une
situation qui risque de dégénérer et une
attitude perceptible de la part des
autorités qui vont de l'impression que
la situation est susceptible de leur
échapper et c'est vrai que ces derniers
jours les diverses manifestations que ce
soit à beyrouth ou à tripoli ont montré
qu'il y avait une modification par
rapport à aux manifestations initiale
des premières semaines en octobre
on n'est plus du tout dans l'esprit
salmiya c'est à dire des manifestations
pacifiques il ya une violence qui est en
train de monter alors évidemment il ya
les mygales l'affichage d'un discours
complotistes on est en orient c'est très
souvent il ya effectivement l'idée
qu'ils auraient une main invisible qui
serait derrière les diverses
manifestations violentes
il ya des tensions incontestable au
niveau politique parce que derrière la
nomination du premier ministre hassan
diable il ya eu des difficultés 1 pour
la mise en place du gouvernement à
partir de janvier dernier
mais on sort de là de la période aussi
de parce qu'on est dans la période post
copie d'un et les problèmes qu'ils
étaient prêts existants prennent un tour
absolument dramatique c'est à dire avec
des vagues de licenciements massifs
il ya un effondrement du pip qui est
prévu à plus de 12% 45% la population
est aujourd'hui passé sous le seuil de
la pauvreté et donc il ya il ya une
dimension clairement émeutes de la faim
qui commencent à surgir et qui est
effectivement problématique pour les
autorités politiques
en russie l'ancien soldat américain paul
ouidane condamné à 16 ans de prison pour
espionnage
l'ex mari dean a immédiatement annoncé
qu'il allait faire appel de cette
décision paul whelan avait été arrêté en
depuis moscou les précisions de notre
correspondant antoine claireaux 16 ans
de prison pour espionnage à l'encontre
de paul willan cet ancien marine
américano britannique qui a également la
nationalité canadienne et irlandaise
l'inculpé qui était présent à l'audience
a tout de suite dénoncé je cite un
simulacre de procès et annoncé vouloir
faire appel de cette décision de justice
arrêté en 2018 à moscou alors qu'ils
assistaient à un mariage
ils étaient en possession d'après les
services de sécurité russes d'une clé
usb contenant des données
confidentielles
lui de son côté estime être la victime
d'un piège d'une machination en tout cas
c'est une affaire de plus qui vient
empoisonner encore davantage les
relations entre la russie et les etats
unis et l'ambassadeur américain en poste
à moscou à d'ores et déjà commenté cette
affaire je vous propose de l'écouter
comme vous le savez je suis de près le
cas de paul depuis mon arrivée ici en
tant qu'ambassadeur en janvier j'ai
décrit ces procédures comme une moquerie
de la justice et aujourd'hui on vient de
le confirmer
un citoyen américain a été condamné à
une peine de 16 ans pour un crime pour
lequel nous n'avons pas vu de preuves
interrogé sur cette affaire le
porte-parole du kremlin a refusé de
commenter cette décision de justice
le kremlin ne s'occupe pas de telles
questions dans ce cas concret je ne
commente en aucune façon la décision de
la justice
et cette situation en particulier il a
été condamné par le tribunal et la
décision du tribunal dit où il a été
inculpé et ces accusations ont été
prouvées devant le tribunal est
confirmée par le tribunal comme dans la
plupart des affaires d'espionnage c'est
parole contre parole difficile de
démêler le vrai du faux
et à en croire l'avocat de paul louis
lannes on s'orienterait vers un échange
de prisonniers entre la russie et les
etats unis une possibilité que les
autorités russes n'ont pas écarté et
pour l'avocat ne pas le wydad le
tribunal aurait manqué de partialité la
décision justice serait politique
je suis profondément déçu par ce
jugement même si nous nous y attendions
ainsi le 2 juin un article a été publié
dans le journal argoumenty nedeli dans
lequel l'un des hauts représentants du
svr le service de renseignement
extérieur a mentionné l'éventuelle
l'option d'un échange de paul whelan
contre iarochenko et buttes
il a donc explicitement admis que
bouteilles à rodtchenko et est affilié
au svr et que nous envisagions de
l'échangé de plus au nom de
l'interpellation de paul le 28 décembre
nous en avions déjà parlé aux agents du
fsb personne n'a caché ça ainsi il ne
s'agit pas d'un jugement équitable d'un
tribunal indépendant où régnerait le
principe d'impartialité
mais d'attention politique
au venezuela l'opposition annonce se
retirer des élections législatives un
scrutin qualifié de farce électorale par
des représentants de onze formations
politiques
dans un communiqué ils dénoncent une
manoeuvre de nicolás maduro vendredi le
tribunal suprême de justice est nommé de
nouveau membre à la tête du conseil
national électoral
un conseil chargé de superviser le
scrutin qui aura lieu dans le courant de
l'année et pour fernandez ancien
diplomate consultant amérique latine la
stratégie de nicolás maduro consiste à
mettre en lumière les dissensions et
l'opposition
on a d'une part une opposition qui dont
le leader le dirigeant et erwan guyot
lui qui représente les factions les plus
radicales de cette opposition pour
partie peu respectueuse de certaines
traditions démocratiques ou en tout cas
qui ne rejette pas les solutions
violentes à principe on a vu l'année
dernière on a priori 2019 un coup d'état
elle est dirigée par lui-même
on a en mai de cette année il a eu une
tentative de de l'opération par des
mercenaires d'une organisation silver
corp et usaid on voit donc une
opposition qui n'est pas homogène qui
est fissurée et la stratégie du
président maduro qui vise finalement à
mettre en lumière ses divisions pour
pour isoler ces factions les plus
radicales et les moins démocratiques est
une opération qui peut avoir un succès
dans le sens où une partie de
l'opposition on le voit aujourd'hui est
tenté par un retour aux urnes et par une
participation à ces élections et c'est
la fin de cette édition merci de l'avoir
suivi prochain rendez-vous avec
l'actualité ce sera demain matin 7
heures du matin heure française quand à
moi j'aurai le plaisir de vous retrouver
demain à 20h excellente soirée à tous
[Musique]
on
bertrand piccard vous vouliez prouvé que
l'on pouvait voyager au solaire et vous
avez fait le tour du monde
moi mon ambition c'est de montrer que
les technologies propres et les énergies
renouvelables peuvent faire des choses a
priori impossible sur leurs épaules
c'était vraiment le laboratoire volant
qui montrait que non seulement on
pouvait s'alimenter au solaire non plus
on pouvait être extrêmement efficients
sur le plan de l'énergie par rapport aux
problèmes là du climat de
l'environnement il ya un état d'urgence
actuellement il ya un état d'urgence
on est en train de détruire la
biodiversité